all righty it is monday
december 6. my my my shout out to you
what the f
family family shout out to his family
family family stop stop
nice sack synced up on this monday
coming up christmas you guys feel it
got the christmas background
it's getting a little cool
it's getting a little nice oh
the christmas lights are coming out
yes i do the fire is crackling
you can feel it coming boy
the jingle bells are in the air
santa's over keemstar's house dropping
coal down his chimney
he's dropping coal down cavs
chimney merry christmas
he's dropping coal down tricia's chimney
and
he's dropping
straight up gold down my chimney
because i
am infallible i have never wronged
or done wrong well what happened to the
music
thank you
all you guys are getting gold bullion
or what were you trying to say what was
the pirate doubloons
you guys are getting gold the blue ins
no doubloons doubloons
close enough these guys are getting gold
doubloons i tell you quet
[Applause]
santa
santa
spotted you all and you're all on the
good list oh
hell yeah and all you guys watching
good list bullions bull but what is it
doubloons
bullion works too yeah
you guys are all getting doubloons
i'll get your word straight jack
but some of you are getting
dazed nuts
[Music]
[ __ ] dude i can't believe you just did
them like that
we're a little bit late sorry about that
guys i know you'll
tape when we're late
i'm trying to wear this dre ela got me
all dripped out in this
sick jacket so sick but it has a little
green on it so we're having some key
issues but
you guys figured it out eh dan in the
end
well i mean it's still keying out a
little bit but
if it's annoying tell us when i can
change because it's still a little uh
staticky
that's just how it looks
in real life
it has invisible thread it's smart
fabric
exactly
today's episode is sponsored by raycon
hello fresh and babel
so yeah this is that teddy fresh drip oh
my god
look at the background there
why is the background [ __ ] up you say
it's my shadow yeah you're casting oh
[ __ ]
is it possible to get a like extra light
on the floor to super backlight it
not right now but
do you think that would help
maybe
okay
just asking questions
just saying just saying just saying but
yes uh
it's a nice time of year what can i say
the family is all
gathered around the fire light
you guys excited for christmas
family family family
family family family family stop
so you guys excited for christmas yes
yeah sure
very
actually we're taking a vac uh uh
we're taking a vacation to us you know
um where are we going
where are you taking us i'm not taking
you [ __ ] i'm just gonna play final
fantasy
what
but we're taking a break is what i'm
saying at the end of this month
so it's tradition we always take a like
three week break at the end of the year
i know i'm sorry melania i know you're a
huge fan of the show
just preparing you guys that we do take
a three-week break
is that right dan we're taking three
weeks off i haven't checked the calendar
uh we are taking
three weeks off from the show yes
yes that's right the hiatus is from the
25th oh god so you guys see we go right
up to christmas day
do you see nobody works like us in the
business
nobody i think we actually said the
wednesday of that week will be our last
show okay
so we'll have a show on the 22nd 22nd
yeah that'll be the the finale for the
year and then we'll be back
on the 17th wow
yeah oh man wow man that's great we're
cooking up a very special episode for
that week oh
baby our final episode of the year is
going to be spectacular
just like every show
every episode is spectacular holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] balls
britney spears of course
giving us a little of her best uh white
cloth gabe impression that's right
all right you want to hit me with that a
little bit more zach holy [ __ ] well
[ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls you know what we
should do on fridays play that
while gabe calls in
[Music]
love that
oh i have exciting news um
the sweater controversy right
with the dinosaur
scandal well we got a hold of the guy
who made it
against all odds
we got his permission
we're cutting them in we've licensed the
dinosaurs
the dinosaurs are gone but not forgotten
my friends that's right and you can now
buy the sweater
thank you to gary kennedy
that guy's super interesting we learned
um
so apparently i think i talked i think i
talked about him a little bit but yeah
he's super interesting he like
got mega rich off these
knitting patterns
retired
it's funny what you can kill them you
can kill the fashion music i need that
thank you
when he when we called him and we're
like yo what about this i guess he had
heard it because i would think everyone
was hitting him up
i was worried about that i don't think
we were gonna annoy the [ __ ] out of him
no i don't think people bombarding him i
don't think it was a bad deal i think he
was just amused by it yeah but he's like
oh that old [ __ ] i made 30 years ago
that was his response
uh
he's a great guy super interesting guy
so gone but not forgotten sweater is
finally available thank you thank you
thank you teddyfresh.com
um let's get right into the flippin show
808 hot meme call in
share your thoughts
on whatever it is
you know
we would love to hear from you
my friends
my beautiful friends
white cloth gabe's getting into the
christmas spirit
ah
enjoying my daily walk with my
peppermint hot chocolate but who gives a
[ __ ] [ __ ] santa doesn't give you [ __ ]
presents if you're lazy [ __ ]
i want my presents baby [ __ ] me [ __ ]
yeah that's why i'm that's why i'm doing
my daily walk almost every day
[ __ ] i want my person's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wow wow wow
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls
what in the world gabe is just on
another level enjoying my daily walk
with my peppermint hot chocolate but who
gives a [ __ ]
nobody does it quite like him eh oh
there's so much power between behind his
cursing he goes from like ah who gives a
[ __ ]
i absolutely love the man
gabe
okay so here's an important thing
so if you go to if you type in
ryan cavanaugh by the way oh boy
let me throw up a new browser here
um
if you type ryan kevin on the search bar
this is gonna be short so don't don't
lose your mind we're not gonna talk
about him but there it so this is
okay so we're
oh no we we dropped we were number four
on the weekend whoops oh no what the
frick what the freak oh no oh no but
we're still we're right below
how is his website ranking above our
website yeah he must have done something
because that that page was like almost
second page
on google what is on his website
he has no pizza i shouldn't click that
by the way you're helping him somebody
pointed out how airbrushed his face is
here
i can't unsee it
look at this perfect skin we stand
perfect skin
i love this
such a good guy
he launched the mcu i mean you can't
take that away from him yeah
the uh
hmm he really did
ghost writer what was it or
yeah
writer ghost writer i'm the ghost writer
he's the ghost producer oh the mcu
that's right
uh what i was gonna say is that we're
building out the does ryan cavanaugh
look like harvey weinstein website and
we're looking for writers we're looking
for talented freelance writers who want
to bolster help us bolster the website
with some
articles so if you if you're a freelance
writer if you're a talented writer this
is paid work of course
um
reach out to i guess uh dan i don't know
sorry dan
or somebody else should we give someone
else's email
it's too late you already said it
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] email us please
you're just gonna get erased and you're
gonna get blocked too right then
that yes absolutely i'm trying to
discourage quick draw on that on that
block button baby we're discouraging
if you are genuine you gotta you gotta
be a real writer with expertise here we
want only the finest articles paying top
coin
for example what was one article we
wanted to uh commission love i forget
sorry what was that what was an article
we wanted to commission we were talking
about
i don't know did we talk about anything
specific
remember
right well whatever is going on in brian
cavanaugh's life as his official uh i
would say myself go ahead
dude sorry but did you talk i thought
you mentioned his dad maybe oh yeah
something about that yeah so his dad
you know who was convicted by
jack kevin i think who was actually a
jury found he was guilty of
whatever all the the the paintings
picasso yeah so i wanted to do like an
article about that for example i mean
as
kavanaugh's self-appointed
chronologer
uh i think it's important it'll be fun
oh we added a section for his dad's
crimes
no that's the message you sent oh yeah
we gotta vet that first before we we add
it
yeah jack kavanaugh was ordered to pay
sands 250 000 in punitive damage and the
jury also awarded sands an additional
3.2 million in
compensatory
comp
compensatory compensatory doesn't sound
right
uh damages all right that's it thank you
i just wanted to give that shout out
here's a nice little meme from the
subreddit by the way
uh someone said they clock in every day
as ethan because i assume no one would
ever look i'm down to taking a selfie
every day my boss just called me into
office with all the pics and said who
the [ __ ] is this
since when do you have to take a photo
of
like what is this technology
yeah i've never had to do that for a job
but um why do you need to take a photo
are they afraid you're going to send you
live in freaking orwell 1982 my dude so
what are you saying watching you
everything i just don't get it is your
work getting done you know what i mean
like why
you gonna send some craigslist guy to
just check in for you
right
i imagine a lot of people probably have
that uh
technology at their work but thankfully
i've never had to do that i'm gonna have
to get you guys to to
i'm gonna need your biometric data i'm
gonna need your
a retina scan
fingerprint scan
a voice scan
and a stool sample every time you check
in no problem
no problem i cannot be having a postures
in here
you've had fingerprint maybe who does
that i've had at a restaurant and i'm at
a restaurant yeah what it's like
how it's like i'm here you all working
together what the [ __ ] my restaurant in
my own uncle's office medical office
and it was used in a book huh
is that just an easy way to check in
clock in though yeah it's a way to keep
everyone honest i guess
because people could share codes and but
how do you fake working a shift at a
restaurant well like let's say
yeah you're running late you want to
cover your friend you like clock me in
i'll be there in five minutes yeah jesus
give the people they do that quite a bit
at the restaurant now that i think about
it so
they work themselves to death where
would we be without men
they deserve to run five minutes late
they're doing impossible things what am
i gonna do women need women need to be
on time
they don't do half the [ __ ] men do
we need fingerprints for women but but
men can be late god damn it
[Music]
you think a woman
can carry as much stuff as a man waiter
he deserves more money
and have you seen their [ __ ]
big bulging beautiful
toxic masculinity
there's nothing toxic about beautiful
male physique
[Music]
oh my lord
thank you zach
somebody said they did the thumb scan to
clock in at the burger king i used to
work at jesus [ __ ] burger king dude
god damn the workforce sucks yeah it's
been a while since i've been in the
workforce you know and actually well
i was in israel for five years so it's
beautiful it's been a really long time
since i've been in the workforce
um but i never had anything like that
you know
like i don't even remember having to
clock it
clock in for anything
it's all on our system
in israel they're pretty lacks about it
like
i managed my own excel sheet
and i just put my time and time out and
then i just submitted it at the end of
the month yeah i've had jobs like that
too but yeah when i worked at a
restaurant for years they they had us we
all had a code and we'd have to clock in
clock out on the computer
ah [ __ ] dude
people are saying my fit is fire thank
you teddyfresh.com my wife tripped me up
dripping me up
yeah i love this jacket it's got a
butterfly on it too and it says
pull yourself together
and that's what i've done
look at you
well look at you
oh also uh h3shop.com you guys are all
you guys coordinated so you guys
coordinated
we just got our samples the samples came
in yeah it wasn't really a coordination
these guys are all dripped out and h3h3
h3h3shop.com
what's this
oh [ __ ] yes apparently this was just
a little bit ago
is an ally bro
[Laughter]
hassan is such an ally you know what
i love hassan he's such a good dude we
have fun
he's just a great guy and a sweet
genuine guy that's right he says nice
things and he says he's just a nice guy
i don't know what to say we love hassan
we stand at all broad-shouldered
masculine king
like i said i want to be best friends
with him
he doesn't mess around with people he
doesn't mess around with people under
six too okay to be
you you want to bring that up again
go ahead okay there
shout out all the food you know the foot
soldiers out there
there was not that big of a difference
that angle was [ __ ] bro when i was
sitting not that big of a difference
okay people are saying we're
exaggerating i've seen those
conversations as well
that angle did not capture when i was
there next to you that i was
and by the way how would i know
if i couldn't visually see it and what
came of you actually being six one and
him being six four i saw and i was like
dude that's like a big height difference
it's it's significant but it's not that
big
you want to measure you want one okay so
you're asking for another
shoulder to shoulder i'm not saying like
i'm as tall as another just saying it's
not as
as significant we need a recount he's
stealing it he's six four and you're six
one
that's fine but i'm just saying it's
fine i'm not saying it's not fine also
there were people speculating that there
was a little you know little
modulation to the height measuring
segment we did well i think we need a
recount on that one um okay so what i
did see was people saying that and you
could pull it up from the subreddit a b
gave me a generous
oh i agree
i saw the photo and i was like okay that
that's a there's a little slack on that
he was stealing
was that intentionally
were you trying to hype me up i have no
idea what you're talking about
i don't need you to hype me up like i
saw how it broke your father and i
didn't want to put you through that
whatever we told gary his height i'm not
saying i'm sick i never said i'm six
foot i said i'm 5 11. let me give you
half an inch same thing
did you do the same to me no no he
probably if any i was back there i
officiated that that was a legitimate
height
i could have stood up a little
straighter just oh like yeah
i stood up straighter just saying dude
you were like all [ __ ]
well michelangelo up here you know well
you're getting your height measured
you're supposed to stand up straight
what are you what are you saving your
what are you saving it for i have a
little slouch to me it's a little bit
you want to get back out i'll
i'll uh measure you again
people i'm saying i'm 5 10 that's
[ __ ]
i'm not 510 you [ __ ]
you want to get that back out that here
let someone else
what measures i want dan because av is
obviously
rigging it i want dan to do it dan can
measure me i don't care who does it
i want a true and accurate measurement i
would like one as well if i'm i don't
care about my height though i'm not
coming around lying to everyone saying
i'm six too why are you so obsessed with
my height i'm just i'm just kidding
i'm just having fun i'm not really by
the way but you were telling everyone
you're six three i did i did eat money
for years
i apologize
but it's not you know it's interesting
at work though we're all like damn he's
so big he's six three yeah no one ever
questions someone that's like over six
foot when they say yeah because why
would they lie
but then
my doctor said i was 6'3
you know i don't think i don't think
that ever happened bro
why would i lie about that why would i
have any reason to lie people are saying
i'm five nine now
no [ __ ] shot
well and then hassan was saying i have
stolen uh short king valor that i agree
with actually when did i when did it
i told you over the weekend you're
colonizing short spaces
you definitely are what have i done i
never said it was sure you're always
yeah but you know these these short
kings
you're overcompensating they can look
out for themselves listen you have tall
savior complex
i think we need a recount listen i'm a
normal height
that's what i think but that's not the
same because if you're a normal height
first of all i'm married i don't care
i'm just
and when i was dating i didn't care
about i only thought about height until
after i was married and my tiny hands
too i never thought about that when i
was dating if i did i would have put
prosthetics over it
like uncle jack from it's always
something yeah
i would have got my height my hand
enlargement surgery
but people are saying i'm here's the
thing
there's a difference between being like
six four
and five eleven five eleven's normal
height it doesn't get you anywhere if
you're over six foot
especially like six one six two over i
saw that i saw a girl she goes even ugly
guys are hot when they're over six too
sorry
olivia what be honest with the height
thing it makes a huge difference don't
lie
i've never been as like
i don't care as much about height as
other girls definitely do i just care
that they're taller than me or same same
height
right so there i mean that alone there
you go height for some reason is a big
deal
i don't know what it is you know guys
worry about the size of their penis all
day it's actually the size of their body
those things often go hand in hand you
would never you wouldn't date a guy
shorter than you
i mean
depends on everything is singular yeah i
don't really you make an exception for
like uh
yeah for like a true king a true
tiny
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now no
he just knows how to dress to work with
his body he's five nine how's that a
dress
no he's not he's must be six foot no
he's he i think he's like notoriously
maybe no he's known for being short
him that's justin bieber after uh
going not standing up straight during oh
measuring yeah he's got that slouch like
zach he's five nine
so there you [ __ ] go
we stand a short king al pacino is five
six
he's like five six he gets a pack and
he's the biggest baddest of all time so
there you go past dude he's the [ __ ]
godfather it's real interesting how lots
of famous actors and and such are
actually short gods
tom cruise he's like short three or
something
i think he's not that short but he is
short
you know what zach's going to be doing
after he got called out five seven
what's that oh yeah this is zach's back
on the weekend this is zach when he
learns he's not 6'4 we play the audio
now
yeah
if i have to do it to get that exchange
be honest though
you know that a guy 6-2 is going to have
way easier time dating wait even if he's
busted ass his face is [ __ ] busted
ass
he's going to have a good old time dude
it's a good thing i'm in a happy
relationship then yeah you probably have
a good time dating because you're tall
i mean i know you're dating but i'm just
saying you guys don't understand what
it's like to be
i'm normal size okay but being short you
know
it's a whole nother league i have
sympathies what can i do
i come from a short family
my family always acted like i was a
freak of nature like my height being 511
that i was like
the chosen one
like i was neo of the family
it's actually the case for my family too
i'm like way taller than anybody in my
family it's odd and so growing up
everyone's like
tall king yeah tall which i'm really not
that tall but
but compared like power over everybody
in my family i i see i look super short
next to my brother who's six five like
that that is a [ __ ] big is he six
five or is he six three listen to what
you just said zach
he i look short next to him okay exactly
listen to what you just said how tall is
your brother six five
okay if he towers over you at six five
how can you be six three that's only two
inches that's that's a difference though
i mean
you said he towers over you bro that's
like a foreign
exaggerating here
anyway you know look height matters i
hate to say it because i'm not tall i'm
normal but if you look at politicians
and leaders they're all super [ __ ]
tall
like on average super tall would you
classify me as normal or tall no you're
tall okay i just want that approval
you're tall okay thank you
that's what i'm saying don't be greedy
bros come out claiming you're six eight
and [ __ ] you already thought
you already have tall privilege
tall privilege yes
i'm gonna start using that
yeah you have tall privilege
yeah does that allow me to manspread
that's
that's whatever you do whatever you want
i'm not getting involved in man
spreading
delete me from this conversation
stop the height hey look i'm just
speaking facts you guys
just speaking facts okay
i'm just spitting facts you know yeah
let's just go burn a uh rod or whatever
the average height of the 45 men who
have served as president of the united
states is approximately 5 foot 11.
overall over history right that's very
impressive right people used to be
significantly yeah
like ceos prominent businessmen stuff
like that yeah james madison was 5'4
damn
people were so little back then people
were a legend people used to be really
really short back in the day yeah
that's all i'm saying
they're saying jealous yes you've got
damn right i'm jealous that i'm not six
too
come come on
god damn right i'm big mad
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it
is there any calls in the queue or is
this thing not logged in properly oh
there is because that oh just hit
refresh okay i don't know why it's not
showing for you i see him
i see him
um let me check the um it doesn't seem
to be working do i need to click this h3
podcast i guess yeah let's try that
click that okay that didn't work
all right so something is off here let
me hack you let me hack the mainframe
yeah go ahead
so uh
[Music]
let me pull something up while you do
that
i go ahead
dan's taken over my computer
we are looking for the calls there they
are
there you go
all right let's see if there's anything
interesting here
jesus
we are coming up on breakdown already
how good has it been 30 minutes well it
hasn't it's been 28 minutes all right
well let's talk about something else
um
[Music]
weird life let's talk about this what do
you think about this love we got a bot
replacement for you
this is like the most intense cookie
notification i've ever got
you know what like guys okay we get it
you're tracking our cookies make sure
you read all read all it i mean let's
just not let's see what you're agreeing
to oh i clicked options and then okay
here i reject all and every cookie now
leave me the [ __ ]
alone whoa this could be you love
but you playing oh really
kill me
i'm in pain
end me please
end
[Applause]
[Music]
kill me
i am soft foreign
can we get the one on the right
i like that one
oh my god come on scott
this is the one that's like kill me and
my suffering
naturally please and me interaction
so imagine there's been a lot of shut up
shut up who's this guy up bro
i'm here for robots not some douche
how much are they
oh whatever
i saw a really funny tweet about this
video saying that irobot takes place 14
years in the future from now and by then
will's going to be too old to save us
and jada's going to take away all the
confidence he has left
yeah i love how um
that red table talk whatever it is on
facebook facebook is just basically
destroying will smith's
reputation how come you don't want me
man
yeah exactly
she's like listen he's never made me
come i don't know what it is
he's just he cannot make me come
i don't know what it is you know he's
big he's tall he's handsome
he just he's never made me uh orgasm
[Laughter]
she has too many knight she's like too
many things this is a problem
she's like he's a big guy but his penis
is really small
like i don't even feel it
micro penis we're talking oh that's hot
she's like so the thing we do is i like
to peg him
not there's anything wrong with that but
it's embarrassing for some people so she
goes i like to bank my husband will
smith he begs me for it
you know i put his little i put his
penis in a cage
[Laughter]
so that's how we make love yeah anal sex
all right let's
oh let's deal with this one here this
this was great this was a mega viral
moment
this [ __ ] what first of all what is
better.com i don't i'm not familiar with
this it's like a mortgage lending
company or something from what i saw
better than
what you know what i'm saying
it's just alone better than what
that's my question you go to better.com
and now they're
websites down oh [ __ ] did they get like
we're doing a little improvements
obviously not better than clearing out
the staff not better than ryan uh does
ryan kevin i look like harvey weinstein
which is up
i trust him
you know i gotta say i'm impressed i'm
impressed love we must have some really
good hosting that that website doesn't
go down regularly dude i've optimized it
i've spent countless hours uh in the
cyber
swiper space and you know
that's all i can say because we crashed
a lot of sites and that one has not has
not crashed while on the show so really
good job shout out to love shout out to
love
you love love
yeah so
the ceo of better.com fires 900
employees over zoom
uh how do these j how do these mass
layoffs generally go
i'm assuming not over zoom
uh probably their manager told
more of a personal right a little a
little more personal than a zoom call
with with 899 other people
yes so the context which is really
interesting is that they picked all the
people that were going to get fired
from all across the country
and they didn't know what the zoom call
was about so they go they're like you
have a zoom call with the ceo they're
like okay what's going on and he's here
to drop the axe on all of them
here it is
would you send maybe
i sent another link in case oh that one
doesn't seem to be oh it's just because
i i just need to play it
thank you
thank you for joining um
i come to you with not great news
um the market has changed as you know
and
we had a market douche the markets are
crazy
houses are on the rise the stock
market's up well and so i don't know all
the details but apparently this company
just
was part of an acquisition and
uh got bought out and so that was like
the further
fuel on the fire of everybody being
pissed at this guy is like he's getting
some
giant compensation package on top of it
all and oh yeah
um i put a little note too uh
i i looked up this guy
and he has a little bit of a story pass
he two years ago
famously uh told his former business
partner and the best man at his wedding
that he was going to staple him against
the [ __ ] wall and burn him alive
he said that at his wedding
no after that's a hell of a fur of a
best man speech
[Laughter]
yeah
well
and i love his little you know plastic
cup full of coke a humble man
why do ceo's got all dressed like this
with like a sleeveless vest it's like we
get it bro you went to stanford and play
golf
[Laughter]
move
with it
in order to survive so that hopefully we
can continue to thrive and deliver on a
mission
so uh bad news we need to fire you so
that i can get my 20 million dollar
bonus it would be impossible well all of
you want salary
and uh well [ __ ] you all merry christmas
this isn't news that you're going to
want to hear
uh
but ultimately it was
my decision
and
i wanted you to hear from me
it's been a really really challenging
decision to make
this is the second time in my career i'm
doing this and i dude this is not a good
way to do this it's like he's making it
like all about himself somebody on
discord just messaged me and said i work
for better.com by softbank
he's my ceo i have a meeting with him
this week
that's what i said i replied uh oh
record it like they did
make sure to record it uh yeah vishal
thank you uh i won't say his name's
i guess i should i don't know where it's
the origin of that name but this
[ __ ] is named garg
gargle these nuts
man these never get easy
that's like the best one of those jokes
i've ever heard
his name's garg
considering it wasn't staged or anything
that wants to
thank you love that it's high praise
coming from love
who crushed us all in the
laughing competition
um garg has been involved in controversy
before as evidence by an email he sent
to staff that was obtained by forbes you
are too damn slow you are a bunch of
dumb dolphins so stop it stop it stop it
right now you are embarrassing me what
the [ __ ]
dumb dolphins
dumb dolphins
you're a weirdo bro
you're weirdo
you're a weirdo bro there it is
all right so let's this guy really
thinks he's like ed stark or someone
he's like if you pass the sentence you
have to kill the man yourself
[Laughter]
you're just some [ __ ] bro with the
vest on it's not that serious
for you anyway for them it is i do not
do not want to do this the last time i
did it i cried
wow sad for you [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] douche nobody cares about
you dude
he's really being the victim in this eh
does he really think the people watching
care that he's going to cry after he
fires them did you did you just say
something about dolphins being dumb
he said he called them dumb dolphins oh
in that clip okay and the email he said
right because everybody's like dolphins
are very smart yes we all know
don't
you know those people have sex with
dolphins like genuinely
very famous story of a researcher who uh
would uh jack them off
uh had like a whole relationship with
one of them
i s i don't know where or why i think
maybe it was on reddit or
twitter
you know i'm not even going to describe
it but it was some dude it was someone
doing that with a dolphin and it was
disgusting it was like actually
traumatic for me to see it was it was
dramatic here this lady margaret howe
love at she was a famous dolphin
researcher and then she researched the
[ __ ] out of those dolphins scandal
because she like fell in love with one
of the dolphins and had a sexual
relationship with it she says you think
the dolphin felt the same way
she said it did
maybe she was right
she is jerk off to this
she has three children are those with uh
yeah they're hybrids no they're hybrids
she taught the dolphins
language
right over a period of two years lily
and lovat
both with very different approaches
tried to prove that human language could
be mimicked by dolphins
her approach was to jerking off the
dolphins while his was trying to teach
them to speak english
i've already taken my curse was more
effective
love it's or experiments and her
relationship with peter the dolphin
right there you go
interspecies sex
wait she didn't write that did she
dolphins are not okay whatever anyways
let's not do bestiality it's too it's
too uh
too early in the show for that yeah
exactly
i'm gonna come
but the truth is if you're gonna have
sex with any animal i would say i mean
dolphins are more sentient than most
creatures so
like if there's consent if there's an
issue of consent probably a dolphin can
consent more than like a dog
pardon me
what didn't you understand
which part are you confused i'm just
kind of jarred right now
i feel like dog and dolphin are
a little equivalent in my brain in terms
of dolphins are much smarter i think the
elephants are significant they're
they're consider they're considered by
most to be sentient non non-human
what do they call them non-human scent
i'm just i'm just saying bro
you know i feel like it's interesting
i'm not saying have sex with dolphins
guys i'm just saying if you're gonna
yeah i mean it's possible a dolphin can
consent you know i'm just saying we're
just saying i think they're [ __ ] high
right now
that's what she was studying yeah she
was she was studying dolphin consent
there's not many animals that can't
consent i mean humans are one of them
what the [ __ ] are you saying they're the
only ones that we know for sure they can
consent
then we can speculate oh
god maybe elephants can consent but good
luck with that
you know what i mean hot dog through the
lincoln tunnel
let's just cut this here
that bad i think it's funny
i don't know
delete me from this conversation
what the [ __ ] oh my god you guys
i can see where you're going with them
i'm just i'm kind of lost on the
other species go ahead ask me anything
i was trying to look up i'm not i'm
making a joke you guys why are everyone
getting so tense jesus christ i'm not
dense not going to go [ __ ] dolphin
i'm trying to find out
where dolphins rank on list of smartest
animals but i gotta say it seems like
every
website that has a list has a totally
different order so it's elephants
dolphins and actually pigs are at the
top too so zach if you're looking for
consent
i believe also dolphins are the other
mammals that uh
mate for pleasure
that is okay dolphin uh all of a sudden
who's sexualizing dolphins now zach i'm
just i'm just spitting facts here
ever
i've gone to like six websites and all
of them i mean it's generally the same
kind of set of animals but the the
rankings are totally different funnels
but it's elephants dolphins pigs well
this one for instance chimpanzees
actually dolphins
elephants at four crows at five uh pigs
at six
uh squirrels
i know statistic about squirrels and
it's that they lose eight out of ten
nuts that they hide they just hide them
and forget where they are trees are
planted [ __ ] yeah it's because they
can't find the nuts that they it's
pretty bad
and by the they're just such prolific
pickers can i tell you an anecdote we
have this beautiful peach tree in our
backyard last year
it
yielded us the most godly fruits of the
earth
uh like hundreds of peaches wow this
year we have these these [ __ ]
squirrels in our backyard that my dogs
are always chasing there's a whole cat
and mouse game or i should say dog and
squirrel game they play indeed
and this year those [ __ ] picked every
single peach there was not a single
peach they took everyone you got raided
bro so i'm just saying those guys are
foolish those guys are good at what they
do man that's true
i like squirrels though despite it all
okay what the [ __ ] is this a.b
it's an interview with the woman who
fell in love with the dolphin
that's three million views how bad can
it be
plenty of thoughts along those lines
peter like to be
don't you dare with me
yes you see so peter's
peter loves it
[Music]
clearly based on the way he twitches his
eye off on my knee or my foot or my hand
or you should be gentle
and i allowed that i didn't i wasn't
uncomfortable with that as long as it
wasn't too rough
peter
had caused margaret some
this is this is disturbing let's not
watch this
stop with the music it's too much for
life
ten times more disturbing with that
music jesus
yeah
well it reminds me we made a video of uh
back in the day if you guys remember
just the right height no bucket required
those guys were [ __ ] up bro it was
about these community of people that
were like they called it zoophiles
and they were openly
um into ponies and horses and stuff like
that
it was super like disturbing but very
funny if you look at it right
he's like and i woke up and my wife was
out in the shed without me and i just
knew
he would call he would call love just
i can't watch it that video got striked
it's like
and for good reason i mean it's so
graphic but
um
ethan straight up trying to say the
dolphin wanted it yeah it's called a
joke riley give me a break bro
[Laughter]
peter drowned himself after she left the
job too jesus
wait seriously that's i mean somebody in
the chat just said that yeah she got
real the dolphin got relocated
apparently
and got depressed killed the man yeah
that's romeo and juliet she once said
that's a romeo julia it's a romeo and
julia situation
so maybe they were in love i mean the
dolphin drowned itself for [ __ ] sake
yikes maybe it was the trauma though i
mean there was stockholm syndrome there
was an academy award-winning film about
a woman having sex with a sea monster
what was it called the sound of water
sound of water that's so true so what's
the point peter
the sound of water i'll tell you what's
the shape of water a big [ __ ]
all right just to be clear i'm just
joking i think bestiality is disgusting
and a crime and all right i'm making i'm
just having fun guys you guys think this
is a joke
jesus christ everyone gets so
what's so mad dolphisy they're not mad
people are alive okay good no people are
laughing dolphusy
[Laughter]
but uh anyway this guy from this video
we watched it's really fascinating and
disturbing documentary if you want to
watch it
but the guy goes ooh it was a little
pony and it was like just the right so
he goes i can just the right height no
bucket required he says me and the
community called those jrbh or whatever
jrh and br these [ __ ] have an
acronym
for how to mount the little pony without
needing a bucket jrhnbr
is there a way to pronounce it
no they just they just say he said it
jrbh nbr
and they're like what does that mean
just the right height
no bucket required sounds like a radio
just the right height no bucket required
coming at you wnbc coming at you
december 6th leave your buckets at home
folks we don't need those
jessie h
oh yeah and he looks oh my god
coming at you oh you mean it's like a
radio we are from jrhp wnr
[Laughter]
leave your buckets at home folks
all right let's do our ads we got three
of them today this call of the day
season i'm sure they'll be thrilled to
be right after that conversation they
should be absolutely this is the number
this is one of the top podcasts in the
world that's right number 26 or
something baby oh yeah that one of the
great quotes was this oh god i want to
watch this but i can't
mirrors do orgasm yes they do it's
called a mergasm he said in the
interview
amerigasm
it's just it's disturbing it's fun it
truly is [ __ ] up that was like the one
video like made me fall in love with h3h
in production
so good
yeah
hello
hello bud
this is a clip hello pretty boy
it's sweetie easy easy
cool
please do come visit
hey baby
he's with a whole crew of dudes who are
jesus
you don't even need to get into the uh
the sexual stuff to just see how
disturbing it is
wow
they've been dieseling the [ __ ]
horses
[Music]
yeah so
we made a whole video about that back in
the day oh god
that's horrific
all right thank you raycon
you know what these earbuds are just the
right height no adjustments needed stop
it just the right size no adjustments
needed
listen
if you want by now you've probably seen
and heard about the thousands of gift
guides for the holiday season you got
gifts for mom because for guys because
for your neighbor's cousin's dog
oh not the dog oh i left that off my
list not the dog no i'm talking about
oh
[Laughter]
you could study all those gift guides
and stop at 10 different places or you
could start shopping at raycon and get a
gift everyone will love raycon wireless
earbuds listen these earbuds crush
they fit perfectly in the ear the audio
is [ __ ]
it's clean
it's kind of a game changer for me
i actually prefer them over the
the big name brands
i use them all the time raycon give you
amazing audio quality wherever you go
whether you use them to pump up wind
down work out
or just go to work they're useful for
anyone on your list even better for you
they start at half the price of other
premium auto brands and with their
latest model you get three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds its best
with just the right amount of bass you
got pure mode balance mode bass mode
raycon's available in five stylish
colors so you can pick a perfect one for
everyone on your list and with free
shipping and returns gifting is easier
than ever
the holidays coming up faster than you
think and now is the time to knock out
that gift list and avoid the last minute
scramble especially because right now my
listeners will get 15 off site wide with
code holiday at buy ratecon.com h3 go to
buyreacon.com h3 and use the code
holiday today to get 15 off your entire
recon order by
uh once again by raycon.com h3 thank you
thank you with peace and love peace and
love
thank you to hello fresh
with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
skip the grocery store
lines skip the trip and count on hello
fresh to make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
number one meal kit we love
the this is abey's burrito
which is the best promotion for this uh
of all time
you just imagine how good it is inside
imagine it
soup
yeah the food troopers send in photos
all the time and it looks amazing
everybody whoa what is that farmer
eggplant parmigiano
sure is oh my god dead parmesan
damn
damn
yeah so here's the deal the footprint
troopers love it these are all photos
they've submitted thank you guys for
sending that in by the way
um it's simple it's fun it's an easy way
to learn how to cook if you don't know
and you're guaranteed a perfect meal
they send you pre-portioned ingredients
that
and fresh ingredients you don't have to
go to the grocery store and buy 10
pounds of carrots
it's cheaper than grocery shopping
ultimately and eating out
and it's super fun they send you a menu
with all the details all the
instructions it's it's great they got 50
menu and market items to choose from
every week including vegetarian calorie
smart gourmet options and provide plenty
a variety save on average over 65 per
month when you order hellofresh instead
of grocery shopping that's more money to
spend on presents and activities
so go to hellofresh.com h3tv and use
code h3tv for up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts
once again that's
hellofresh.com h3tv
14.
uh america's number one meal kit thank
you to hellofresh
all right
and babble
babble
thank you thank you learning a new
language can feel intimidating but when
i first decided to give ian what'd you
try french
uh yes i did how was that for you
that was great respond in french
uh we
oh it worked wow
thank you why are you learning french
you got plans just just for fun
say something
huh prove it say something
well yeah i was when i took the subway i
kept saying to zach
[Music]
what does all that mean i go to the
train station and i take the train i
think
i took french in high school and i'm not
good at it at all but sometimes ian will
say something and i'll try to translate
it he crushed that he does a great job
i do an okay job i'm only a couple weeks
in i'm like three weeks in and i took it
for four years
one thing i say all the time is jamaan
pizza i eat
pizza
yeah he's already talking about moving
to france he's always given he's ready
to give it up yeah and he's gonna start
smoking cigarettes it's great though
that's a good endorsement
well
it sounds great you know thanks to babel
ian is crushing it
number one selling language learning app
the whole process is fun fast and easy
whether you want to learn a new language
for an upcoming trip or as an engaging
new hobby babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons for free real world
uses babel's 15-minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go other language learning apps
use ai for the lessons plan but babel
lessons were created with over 100
language experts their teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to be
effective and with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babbles speech recognition technology
helps to improve your pronunciation and
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20 day money back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now if you purchase a three
month subscription with babel you get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three go to
babel.com and use the promo code h3tv
that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code h3tv babble language for life thank
you thank you
all right
all righty
so moving on from the um bestiality
we never finished this what the [ __ ]
forgot we were watching this we only 50
minutes into this
all right and where were we
[Applause]
i kind of want to wait for dan to come
back because he's like the socialist
he's gonna
get so triggered over this you know
but okay let's let's push on without him
this time i hope to be stronger
but we are laying off about 15
of the company
you gotta be kidding me
efficiency
and
performances
oh he so he says performances so he's so
he's saying well actually you guys just
suck at your job
sounds like it
so why are you so sad then
you gotta be kidding me
efficiency
and
performances
that's awesome
we did for the company
if you're on this call
you are
part of the unlucky group being laid off
your employment here is terminated
effective immediately
what does this mean for what's next
you're going to get an email from hr ask
hr at better.com and your benefits
we're all u.s employees we're providing
foreign
oh my god i can't believe this damn i
feel bad for us hitting her hard yep
[ __ ]
it sounds like it hurt because she was
like after all i did for the company too
[ __ ] you dude
one month of full benefits and two
months of cobra for which we will pay
the premium so don't you have to pay
cobra like literally that's your
obligation [ __ ]
[ __ ] freak ass is even giving them
severance u.s employees we're providing
foreign
oh my god i can't believe this one month
of full benefits and so wait did he say
anything about segments he did just now
four weeks of severance okay
i can't believe this one month of full
benefits and two months of cobra for
which we will pay the premium so three
months
total benefits if we um if you like for
cobra this is not real thank you for
each and every one of your individual
contributors yeah i feel horrible for
her
i wish the news was you know what if
this guy was brave and actually if this
guy wants to prove how brave he is turn
on the audio from all the other people
if he wants to [ __ ]
really be the tough guy he is then you
gotta listen to them different
i wish we were thriving it can't be
enthusiastically as it were at the
beginning of this year
that's not the case
and
i am sure
you will leave us
[Music]
apparently works at better.com uh
says that he did not want to give them
severance
um and that there's articles about it so
i'm looking into that right now he did
say on the call they get four weeks of
severus
you know
we did [ __ ] here yeah i mean four weeks
isn't that isn't that bad i don't know
how long they work there and stuff it
could be worse he could guess give him
no sense in your next endeavor i wish
you all the best of luck
thank you for everything you've done for
better
thank you see you you missed the part
dan where he says we're firing you some
of you for performance
so he's like well you some of you just
suck at your job too we're through some
of you suck at your job the rest of you
no reason there's really no reason yeah
all right well shout out to the
gag or get gang gang garga garg guard
gang shout out
that [ __ ] is cursed
stop
oh wow sweet uh love love said that in
sweden if you get fired
you get 60 to 80 of your salary until
you find a new job is that if you're
fired or also if you just leave
uh i think it's supposed to be mainly if
you have to quit your job or
like if you have to quit your job for
whatever reason like if you don't like
it
for whatever and if you get fired mainly
i guess so you'll get yeah
i mean there's unemployment here in the
united states but it's not 80 of your
salary
yeah it just hit me when i heard her
like be that upset i don't think that
would happen in sweden honestly it's
very sad yeah it's sad and also i don't
know if you caught it but they're like
we're paying for your health insurance
for three months and then you're then
you have no insurance
no health insurance bro
we got that for free here of course you
do
yep apparently the senior leadership
team had threatened to resign in order
to get him to agree to at least four
weeks of severance they wanted at least
60 days but he wouldn't hear of it okay
okay well good job to the senior
management team
for those for advocating for that
they're next up on the job yeah exactly
well if you
if you fire them
after they've been there for that long
without any severance that would be
really [ __ ]
he's like you will get no severance and
no insurance
i'm ending this zoom call i nev you you
will never hear from me again
sad stuff but it is that's the world
baby
it's better.com
better than what
we still don't know
so you can retire better
so he can retire better
uh another weird disney edit i thought
spiderman is in fact peter parker
my entire life got screwed up
yeah they can't be claimed bruh
wait what's worried about this it's just
a trailer it the it's literally the next
line and it is the one that's edited
okay could you make it so that mysterio
never revealed my attack
[ __ ] you guys
stop
you guys are marvel what the hell this
is like the biggest budget movie
in years right
can you guys seriously stop could you
make it so that mysterio never revealed
my identity
can you make it there's a stereo
holy [ __ ] dude
this is the first time for me in the
marvel universe never forget owen who
made it all possible
he
180 milli that's pretty big right
[Applause]
180 million is the budget on that film
you think they could hire a [ __ ]
editor
i mean what they spent on adding that 50
bucks from like uh fiverr
this is the first time for me
in hi my name is aquafina and i am in
the movie
all right this next one is pretty spicy
guys
this is a
a lightning rod issue
so we have to approach this with utmost
delicacy
okay
so this person i guess this is ironic uh
post no look who it is wait who's
no [ __ ] way yeah that's why i put it
in here oh i thought this was ironic
that i read it oh that's almost no it's
ali
our favorite trans-racial yeah he's gone
korean
no okay so then she really [ __ ] up i
feel like if she's being shouted out by
ollie
the tweet is so [ __ ] i i didn't see
it was ollie i really thought someone
was goofing her
i'm so in love with ariana grande's
new asian look it looks so cute and
oriental bro like that's racist
that's racist to say that isn't it yeah
that's that's a racist like he should
know better because he's like wanting to
be transracial you'd think that you'd be
more sensitive
he's i mean he's asian so at least you
know
he's like i can say that i'm asian
i'm south korean
i can't believe he said that welcome to
the trans-racial club ari oh my god you
really ruined her yeah she that's it
you did this is not oh lord help me
so happy to have you join me can we
become king and queen of korea together
already
dude
so this is the look and i guess she
erased the i guess she got a lot of [ __ ]
right
yeah
i was
looking at it i think these photos
specifically her face looks super washed
out and it looks like
it looks like she edited i was talking
to sam and it looks like maybe her
eyelids were like i don't see her
eyelids
which is
weird but then if you look because she
has been doing her makeup differently if
you look at like photos of her on the
voice it's a little bit less
drastic
only a mask i was trying to watch videos
on um asian fishing to educate myself
but i don't know what did you learn
about asian fishing i learned that it's
pretty prevalent these past few years
um
especially in like twitch culture
people have been asian baiting and like
tick tock when tick tock wait what does
that mean to asian bait
to try to make your eyes a different
shape when is that when you're
pretending to be asian when you're not
or yes yes it's like black fishing like
when people oh okay yeah
wow
only a master of the four races can save
the pop world
wind
earth
fire
water
the avatar possesses all four elements
[Laughter]
oh yeah and people are saying that she
had you know those like thread lifts
that make your eyes go upwards yeah
people are speculating that she had that
done
oh so she is like ollie well so actually
i was learning recently that this has
become a popular surgery the kardashians
did it
um what's her name the model
bella hadid no no the kardashian um oh
kendall yeah kendall had that done all
of them have it done they get the
surgery that lifts their eyes like this
i didn't know people were doing that
yeah
here let me see if i can find like a
before and after
but so i guess that is kind of is that
like asian baiting i mean i i don't know
i'm i don't know how to be sensitive
about it but is that considered like
or is it just if you're trying to
get surgery to make your eyes look asian
yeah i would say so i don't know if it's
necessarily trying to look asian it's
like
sort of a facelift but it's also yes so
so what they do is they
which makes the eyes i don't know
it's but apparently it's a nice it's a
look that all these models are doing i
didn't know
oh my god bro there's different degrees
to it i mean there are definitely some
that are completely trying to be like
asian
uh but other ones yeah this is the
cardinal ones
yeah
no it also had like so many i mean
there's so much going on there you can't
even
it doesn't look like she's asian dating
but the surgery is interesting if you
google a fox eye lift
that's what the surgery is but you can
see how much work they get done guys you
can buy you can just be
you can just be a supermodel if you have
enough money it's kind of crazy this
family proves it man
you know
it's crazy
it's crazy
what's it called fox eye lift
so you think she had this procedure
i don't know i mean it's really popular
right now
that's like a one-way street like you
can't undo that [ __ ] no you can't i
think you could undo it i think all they
do is they put they like insert a string
oh god pulls it up and it tugs i hate
that and then they why would you want a
string in your entire skin
yeah
yeah so
it makes the eyebrows go up
it just pulls the skin back eh somebody
said arigato grande
no
no no no no no i don't want to get
canceled by the ariana's we love we
stand we stand a queen right ian
yeah right ian
well ian's aria grande stan i know that
i like the music yeah
oh but bella had deeds is out of control
yeah she ended up shooting way too far
with it
she was i think like one of the first in
the
that group of friends to get it hold on
bella hadid
and then you call it
fox lift
or what do you call it
fox eye lift fox eye lift before and
after
let's see
interesting
that's very interesting eh
golly
um
interesting
what the heck
it's a huge difference
i mean she's pl she's she's pretty here
we don't need to pull the skin back like
i bet if you look behind her head she
got like a uh
a chip bag clip on the back of her skull
are you saying that was a bad taste joke
or you don't know well that isn't no i
just want to shake my head at me
people do that with makeup there are
these like stickers oh for real yeah and
then you pull it and you connect it in
the back
yes celebrities for like events do that
what the [ __ ] man there's all that kind
of black magic going on i'm not even
aware of it reminds me of a mrs
doubtfire that one scene when they're
trying to find her makeup
i guess i don't remember yeah exactly
did oh
exactly
yeah interesting stuff
yeah that kind of blew my mind when i
found out about this fox eye lift or
whatever
you know
jesus she looked like unhealthy on this
side she's like beautiful normal looking
or one beautiful girl
how do i say put this in a way
okay that's not even
but okay
so we're suspecting ariana grande
ariana arigato grande
arigato arigato grande
fox let's see if there's any
fox lift
if there's any
data points here for us to consider
oh it's not working
you're being accused of doing some
fishing right now ethan what did i do
you're canadian fishing
no because of your flannel jacket and
beanie
as long as i'm in the good company of
jordan peterson then
right i'll be canadian
here's plastic shirt well this is like a
weird photo bro
here
i mean it's hard to tell i just see
makeup usage
yeah it doesn't really seem we need a
more um modern photo
oh my god
well that's also the way she did her
makeup yeah but it's just kind of
disturbing
i sent a tweet in defense of ariana oh
we have good good good good thank you we
need we need defensive we need to defend
our arigato
grande
all right we have our eyes over the
years
here we go a full study
um
these are your eyes on crack these are
your eyes on heroin
okay let's let's examine closely so it
looks just like that meme eyes eyes eyes
eyes
eyes
i don't know i mean
it's kind of intense looks like they
have the same shape just different
makeup different eyelashes and she like
very recently when she started on the
voice started doing her
makeup different ravioli
did you know it said ravioli on the
bottom well i just pulled up the people
do a million versions of this meme
okay well anyway and and the issue of uh
so can you show me the people that are
angry about this like are there actually
people angry or because i know there's
this is like a hot very passion lots of
passions between the two camps here
and i don't want to anger anyone because
honestly i just don't care enough to
either way or maybe i should care maybe
i do care but olivia tell me which side
i should care about
i think we should
definitely
be aware that this might be happening
and keep an eye on it
okay
it was the photos that she posted the
other day that everyone was like
excuse me and then she deleted them is
there more photos from this photos
edited because like yeah well i think
like those exact photos that she posted
she has no islands look at this yeah
this appears to be okay good good this
is what i wanted i wanted to see it from
a different perspective yeah she's just
doing i mean i don't i don't know i
think that the she did post those photos
where it looks like she doesn't have
right an eyelid but i think she looks it
looks so much more uh severe in the
photos yeah they must have been shopped
and sometimes this is just a look and
then i think someone did her dirty as
[ __ ] she's also incredibly washed out in
those photos right but what is this one
why does an array of weird
that's very weird but yeah i mean if you
look on the right here or
if you look at that you're switching
back twitter
that's doesn't look like a an asian fish
to me right we agree on that you mean
her right here yeah and yeah here i
don't i don't really
see it but
what is it about the photos that are
that like is it just the makeup it looks
like she doesn't have any eyelids yeah i
think it's that and it's also she's
super washed out from
i suspect her setting powder i would say
i understand i guess if people are
sensitive about this because it's
happening all the time especially with
these absolute psychos like ali
who who's like super weirdly racist in
his attempt to become yeah he's just
straight up calling him orientals like
what
um but it seems like her intentions were
not to do this so i would take it easy
on our on our queen uh arigato
[Laughter]
and um
i i think it's clear that that this was
just a an honest mistake i would i would
i would say based on this video we have
here or this gif
do we like this answer are we happy with
this answer i'll change my opinion if
you guys want i really don't care i just
don't want people to be mad at me i feel
good about your answer okay personally
yeah just let me know if i need to
change my answer and i will okay guys
cool
i'll keep you posted
yeah um agree ethan we got crazy how
she's able to change her face so much
uh we've got uh
i saw someone in the chat said um
their chat was like i'm asian and i have
a lot to say about this so if we can
find them
maybe
sure but you know that's that's probably
just going to get me in more trouble
oh boy
people are agreeing with me safe answer
ollie are tweeted about it is only
watching our show right now
wait only two weeks talking about the
tweet that we already yeah i'm pretty
sure
huh why would they be saying he tweeted
about it then check this out because
they
because they weren't paying attention
because we're paying for they just came
in late
ethan we like your true takes thank you
guys sounds like i don't need to change
my opinion right now change your opinion
right now somebody said
all right she needs to stop she needs to
be canceled
people are saying ollie tweeted about it
why are they lying well they're not
lying he tweet he did tweet about it
they're not aware that we already
covered it
okay i'm on twitter right now
they're just talking about the tweet
that we already showed well guys we
already talked about it with the time
give us the program people
oh let's go to calls we haven't taken
any calls let's see if we got anything
interesting
um
drake has withdrawn his two grammy
nominations is that because he was about
her he didn't get album of the year nom
i i don't know i'm just seeing the
headline on trending on twitter do you
have any intel on that ian
uh i this is my first hearing about it
but it's the first people for me have
issues with the grammys you know like i
think the weekend pulled out last year
just people don't don't like it oh okay
interesting yeah reps for drake did not
immediately respond to requests for
comment
so we don't know yet
we'll keep a close eye on on drake
okay so we have um
kiana who dates a short king
that's [ __ ] that's interesting let's
go
all right kiana so obviously uh shout
out
for
uh dating a tiny legend
kiana
oh my god hello all right so how how
tall is your boyfriend
he's like he says he's five foot four
but he's like just under five foot four
so that is
that is actually a short king he's
yeah he is the short king okay now let
me ask how tall are you
i'm five foot eleven oh my goodness you
were like
that's super tall
yeah it's a huge high difference so wait
where does is his height his face must
be like your belly button when you guys
are standing up
yeah he's like literally at my shoulder
it's um
quite
comedic but we've been dating for seven
years so it's
yeah it's not really as funny anymore
did you guys do mommy dom
maybe
zack said that question i blamed that
that was exactly what yeah i didn't i
don't want to own that one
all right so okay that's real
interesting that's a huge height
difference so
tell me about it
yeah um i don't know it's just i kind of
just how you were saying that hype
matters and it's funny because when i
like growing up even like in middle
school i always just said that i would
never ever date anybody
even like the same height as me they
always had to be taller
but uh yeah then i met him seven years
ago he was so short and i thought he was
so weird
and then he ended up being super great
so i don't know i feel like this is just
my way of coming on insane to give short
guys a chance so basically um you were
into tall guys being a tall you know
girl yourself most girls don't want to
date someone's shorter yeah so but so
when you first met him there was no
physical attraction
no not at all and then was he kind of
aggressively pursuing you
how did that happen or was it a
friendship no i
yeah we have like this kind of funny um
like meeting story he actually tried to
hit on my friend who is his height
and then we went over to his house that
night and then
i ended up getting kicked out of my
house that night and then we hung out
together and then i really liked him we
hung out like every single day we've
like never spent a day away from each
other now like yeah we're like best
friends
i don't know where love got this but
apparently this is a accurate depiction
of your guys's bodies does this look
true to how the [ __ ] did you make this
love
there's a height comparison website so
just put in two values yeah so does this
does look this look accurate to you wait
5'3 that seems tall my stream is so
delayed
okay
well
until that until it catches up
the people of it oh
no it's actually a little bit worse than
that
he's a little [ __ ] like he's literally
at my shoulder he's 5'3 love that seems
generous
she said 5'4
we're gonna get a new chart for you okay
it's
it's so funny people like i've had
people say good for you
just because i'm like like i'll tell
them my boyfriend's five foot four and
they'll be like oh my goodness that's
good for you
yeah what the hell okay
all right so you guys you guys became
close friends
and then so did he make the first move
on you how did that happen
no yeah we hung out for like i think it
was maybe after two weeks of hanging out
we i don't even know
probably i think it was like a little
bit of both it was really like just a
genuine yeah like connection it was yeah
okay
so and then
you don't remember who made the first
move okay
um and then basically i think it was
like a little bit of both you know like
i was only 16 so it was like it was like
young love oh wow okay interesting
and so do you ever give him piggy backs
or anything like that
yes
all right here we found we finally
worked it
i think this is right
does that look accurate
he's like 30 seconds behind yeah
you know in like yeah like a minute
okay so okay great and he's and then
like uh
that's awesome i mean great for good for
you i'm i'm super happy i mean i don't
find this that and like i know that
there's that stereotype that girls like
to date taller guys or whatever but i
mean there's that one but she's 5 11. so
she is extremely i mean it's a
significant height difference yeah but i
mean nobody raises my eyebrow i want to
go yeah definitely i'm tall
yeah you're super tall
and so and and i hate to ask this
forgive me if it's on coup if you don't
have to answer me of course oh boy here
we go
feel free not to answer but like in the
bedroom everything's satisfactory
yeah everything's great everyone it's
this this old lady that i used to work
with used to always tell me like because
when she found out i was dating someone
that's five foot four she was like oh my
goodness
that's a big difference but everyone's
the same height in bed
interesting is that true and that
remains true oh [ __ ] hell so if
you're short your dick probably looks
hella big which is like a plus i think
for a shortcut oh interesting
relative challenge
that's awesome okay well i mean shout
out to him he sealed the deal with the
with the tall beauty
and uh good for him and good for you too
i mean you know
god damn
and good for you you sound like you're
special
good for him good for you good for
everyone
you see the chart by the way is that one
accurate
yes that one is more accurate
awesome
love that
all right well hey true love can find
you anywhere
[Music]
uh even in a all right let's not even
make fun yeah we love him and uh we love
you thank you kiana
thank you so much all right take care
there you go you see
short men can
date tall women
i feel like you make it so much more
awkward than it means to me
well i'm just trying to get to the truth
dan i don't know what you want from me
i really
just doing my job
um oh god pro nose picker i mean i'm not
it's not that i'm against nose picking
this person says they're pro nose
picking and want to debate me
i'm not against nose picking i just
think boogers are really gross and i
don't want to see someone picking their
nose in public but like
i mean in privacy in private i think
most people pick their nose right yeah
sometimes you just gotta get it out of
there i mean sometimes i try to use a
tissue
i pick with a tissue over my finger
because yeah that's that i think it's
gross
i mean what do you want to what do you
want to debate me here on frank i mean
i'm i'm pro nose picking just don't do
it in front of me is that okay
yeah i i will say for the record that is
different from what you've said in the
past though what did i say in the past
hmm call out
very very adamant of not even wanting to
speak about it
hmm
do you have an episode you have a time
stamp and i can pull up that so we can
uh bust him with some evidence here time
stamp me or it didn't happen
no i i'm sure in a few days the super
troopers will have it on the reddit that
i i i'm sure somebody will probably say
listen i i i'm there i just remember you
you had said
it was like very repulsive when someone
had brought it up and you said that you
didn't
you said something along the lines that
there's not one time you saw someone
pick their nose that it doesn't
immediately go to their mouth
and then i think you stated that you you
you don't pick your nose either
so
there was a someone brought up a medical
thing of like
oh people do it for medical reasons too
you eat your boogers bro yes
you eat your buggers do you want your
boogers dwight yeah do you eat your
boogers no
okay because it sounds like that's where
you're going you're like
defending bugger eating
defending
okay i mean i i i do find boogers gross
other people's boogers is like super
gross and i mean
you know
that's kind of my my boundary on that
but uh you never stick your bare finger
in your nose to get one out yes i do i
do
oh
oh okay i feel better i feel a lot
better all right thank you frank i'm
glad we could resolve that
all right take care
thank you
um i'm being told that number 67 is a
real juicy collar
okay
if you take a look at that little
summary there all right let's hear about
it i'm interested
okay we've got uh
stacy
who's uh has a dating experience she
wants to share with us
uh yes hi um
so
i'm very glad that you didn't give away
the punchline to the story but um i've
never shared this before and never
thought i would ever speak of it but
it's been so long now that i figured it
would be um good for a little bit of
content love it yeah i've gotten better
by the way
i'm not giving away the punchline of the
story
so i'm i'm working on it stacy and i
want it to be good so let's hear your
dating story
okay um so i
met this guy probably definitely over a
decade ago
um we worked together
and you know things kind of got hot and
we hooked up and it was supposed to be
this one time thing and it turned out to
be you know
an every couple day thing we worked
together and so we traveled on the road
a lot and so we would always be in hotel
rooms it was really anonymous and nice
whatever what did you guys do
what brought you guys to be traveling so
much
we i would rather not say um we we did a
lot of um construction work for big
companies okay that kind of summarizes
it a little bit okay um so the holidays
are usually like our down season so
our hotels were kind of put on hold for
a little bit so we had to find a place
to go and so the next logical conclusion
was his place um and what i didn't
really know at the time was he was
renting a room from a family which was
fine no big deal um you know he said
super private tonight
so when you say he's renting a room from
a family you're talking about
going into the home
and
he's inside their home
yes wow
and i feel like i have to set up this
story just a little bit to kind of
explain
you know the final outcome of it all but
so yeah so basically he was renting one
bedroom um in this huge house
and so you know he said it's no big deal
i can have visitors blah blah blah
so i show up one evening and i give him
a call before you know i actually
approach the door and say hey i'm here
and he said no just knock on the door no
big deal so i knock on the door and
there's this very large man there and
i've never met him before i said hey you
know i'm here to see so-and-so and the
guy just kind of grunted and i see my
fella behind him so you know we carry on
and do the deed and after that you know
we start talking and i say who's that
and
he says um you know he's the father of
the family
he just got out of jail um you know a
couple weeks ago he doesn't speak much
english and he's kind of separated from
the family but you know he really had
nowhere to go so they kind of treated
this man very
almost i hate to say it but like a dog
um he he slept
on a mattress underneath the dining room
table
um
he would vacuum the entire house
he slept under the table
under the dining room table on a
mattress was it
was it cramped for space why was he
under the table no this was a huge house
and i mean i never really got the full
story exactly of this guy's theo but he
was kind of an integral part of like the
whole story because he was just so weird
he
i i really don't understand this was a
huge house it seemed like there was
probably somewhere else for him to sleep
but he slept under the dining room table
um he liked it you know
maybe he did
he would vacuum the entire house which
is
you know not a big deal but it's kind of
weird when you know you try to go use
the bathroom and he's vacuuming up the
sink in the vacuum or in the bathroom
um so like just really odd behavior i
would go over there sometimes in the
afternoon and
he would have like am stationed radio
stations blaring but they were kind of
out of um out of range so you'd hear
like a lot of static just just weird it
was uncomfortable but i guess you know
uh the relationship at the time was
enough to ignore the whole situation
um so this went on for a little while
and
my stays became a little bit more
frequent
um we would order food and you know have
a good night and kind of i would stay
over the night
um
and when my thing
became a little bit longer
you know i would need to go use the
bathroom and this gentleman would be in
the bathroom vacuuming the tub and the
sink and it would have to leave
yeah
he's using what kind of vacuum is he
using
dyson it was like an upright like not a
dyson
but like like an upright vacuum that had
like a hose attachment so he didn't have
the whole thing so he was putting the
hose attachment in the bathtub
yeah so it sounds like he's gotta look
maybe a screw loose i don't know well
maybe honestly and i think because of
the language barrier like i i tend to be
pretty friendly and if i'm in somebody's
house you know i would try to make
promises okay so every every time you
need to go every time you need to go to
the bathroom this dude is in there
vacuuming
yeah okay so okay so i follow
got it yeah so i mean just weird things
around the house which kind of like
restricted us to the bedroom mostly
um
and for my
my gentleman man friend he he had no
problem you know relieving himself here
or there in a bottle or two um and i
never found that to be so weird you know
i've been around guys car trips and
stuff and that's just what they do
but at home in his room
he was peeing in his room
i hate to tell you this damn but i know
guys i've never done that i find it
disgusting but i know people
i had a friend
who was like i don't go i don't get up
and pee in the middle of the night i
just pee in a bottle and put it next to
my bed but was he doing it in front of
you
no no he was just telling me oh her yeah
he would be in a ball in front of you
yes that's weird yeah it would be like a
middle of the night situation where like
oh i'm just going to do this because
dude's in the bathroom
at the time did he ever miss did he ever
pee on the i don't know i don't want you
know i suspect that there might have i
mean i don't have that equipment but
i've probably thought about this a
little too much and you know when it's a
two liter uh sodi bottle i i don't know
how much you can really
get in there with accuracy so maybe but
i i don't know that much
in my baby love is saying
love is saying he'd rather pee in a
bottle
if there's a dude in the bathroom all
the time well okay that's fair
so there's something that's really kind
of why i excuse the whole situation
because i mean i i i
would have to leave if i needed to use
that i'm assuming things escalate right
that's not it
yes um yeah so you know this goes on for
a couple weeks we order takeout pretty
much every night at this point and his
room is starting to kind of pile up with
takeout boxes and at this point i'm kind
of just like this is disgusting we need
to do something about this or this is
this is over you know the whole thing
kind of ran its course anyway so i was
kind of looking for an excuse to get out
but i said you know hey we've got pizza
boxes everywhere your room's kind of
starting to smell we've been using it as
kind of just like a trash house for the
last you know couple months let's get
this place cleaned up
and he was a little
he was a little not okay with that you
know he kind of rushed around and picked
everything up he's like oh you don't
have to worry about it like i know it's
our mess but it's my room and i really
should respect it blah blah blah
so we clean up a little bit and um
kind of get back to you know the antics
and i just couldn't
escape the funk that was in the room and
i had to investigate so
he ended up going out to his car to go
get something
and i took a peek in the closet and it
was stacked
with two liter piss bottles and to go
containers full of species no [ __ ]
oh no
how did it not smell
the smell of the
mussels that point there were more
bottles
to be quite honest after that discovery
i i really didn't like
sort out how many boxes of [ __ ] there
were but i i
saw what i needed to see and that was
kind of like the nail in the coffin but
there were
there were okay wait countless bottles
let me ask some questions there's [ __ ]
all over the floor
let me ask some questions
what kind of to-go boxes are we talking
about like the styrofoam kind of fold
opens are we talking like what are we
talking about no
like the plastic chinese ones like with
the lids like almost
the little ones
that's one word the rice holder no i
think like the black bottom with the
plastic top are you talking about like
the plastic the pla big rectangular
plastic one
correct that is so shallow
that is so shallow
that's a good point and then they see
put he puts the top back on like it's an
order that's ready to get shipped out
[Laughter]
did you see any toilet paper
oh god no i i have never even i never
even thought that far i've i've been
holding this for so many years do you
realize he probably wasn't even wiping
his ass
what a shame
[Music]
i mean disgusting every now and then
when i think about it it's a shame that
it it it came to that and i mean the
whole story i mean this character guy in
the house i kind of only told you about
it to kind of set up the whole bathroom
part but
the whole story itself is just too much
to believe sometimes but that was it
okay well hold on hold on it was hold on
i have more questions
did you panic when you saw the boxes or
did like what happened when you saw the
boxes you must have been panicked it
well
i mean yes i panicked that
to be quite honest i mean the amount
there were way more piss bottles and
again i didn't i didn't go counting the
to-go containers but like there were way
more kiss bottles than [ __ ] but you
opened the container and you saw [ __ ]
dude i mean why are we trying to
downplay that i didn't open the
container i did see it through those
like it was see-through see-through yeah
dude
what did it look like was it a log or
was it like mush
i don't remember it
i mean it was okay so did you leave it
immediately
did you leave a meteor or did you yeah
yeah did you just be like i gotta go
something came up
i well no i was just like this is this
has gotten too much for me at this point
and we're we need to just kind of end
this and did he ever figure out what you
found
oh he knew it was like a sling situation
so it wasn't like i was full on dating
this guy it was just kind of like we
were having a really good time and it
that was when it kind of
ended it for me that was enough and you
guys worked together so what was it like
at work after you found out he shits in
a box and keep stores in his closet
so thankfully at this point that was
like when it was our down
and because we kind of we lived a couple
of we lived a state away
so it wasn't like so because of this
time of year we actually weren't around
each other too much and then when the
year picked up he actually ended up
moving back home to his home state
because he could he was renting this
room he did he wasn't really even from
around here
um all right well i'm sure his uh i'm
sure his uh parents will be happy to
have him back in their house
[Music]
you know it's funny because after pretty
much everything uh went down the way it
did i i thankfully really didn't have
too much contact with him after that and
i've had a few people over the years say
like oh have you ever heard from
so-and-so and i'm like no
no nope well stay tuned for social media
and all that stuff so thank you for
sharing i'm sure he's a listener right
yeah hopefully
don't guys at home do not [ __ ] in your
boxes thank you stacy for sharing that
thank you so much heartwarming christmas
uh special they're a beautiful christmas
story for you they're not taking a pause
to [ __ ] all over them maybe it was
jeremy though maybe the timelines add up
she said about ten years ago maybe that
was maybe jeremy he met his wife oh my
god a little came out i'm seeing a lot
of people in the chat saying that shane
dawson is a bottle pisser he is why
would you
what
because he revealed that himself do you
have some media i can watch about he's
talked about it a bunch i think he did
like a house tour
i think i saw that in the chat i mean
guys let me just say if you're dating
let me give you some easy [ __ ] layup
here if you're dating and you bring a
girl back to your room
at least bro take the piss bottles out
[Music]
take the piss bottles out guys
oh you know what if you want to leave
the piss bottles at least take the to go
boxes full of human feces
out
don't worry we'll blur it
hey
ew you disgusting [ __ ] freak
you how can you leave a piss bottle on
your calendar when you have guests over
that's in that bottle right there it
seems like maybe you might have pissed
into it because you were too lazy to get
and go to the actual bathroom shane is
that piss no
shane is that piss do you want me to
test it
he actually is okay you can stop it i
have no interest in watching this he
actually is a such a perverted
degenerate like knowing what i know
about him now and watching him just
discussing his piss bottle like it's
some cute thing the dude is demented bro
that's sick it is it is it's perverted i
think it is knowing everything i know
about him now
aren't you worried about leaving a
pissed stain on your furniture like he
puts a piss bottle on a red wood he's
gonna get a ring you need a coaster for
that piss bottle dude yeah at least he's
a coaster
you see how well trained i am now
if you want to watch a streamer that
wants to pee in the potty oh my god
there's so many defecating sound bites
by the quartering it's all like i feel
like how people talk about like
boys peeing in bottles
but not saving it that's when you're
like a
teenager or i've literally only done
that on a road trip
once as a grown [ __ ] man who owns a
home who's has guests and who has guests
in his room yeah it is it's it's it's
humid you need to you should be
humiliated by that if you do do it have
the decency to be humiliated by it
maybe it's just because i watched like
those youtubers growing up so i just
assume it's normal that is
not normal i mean it's listen nothing
about that man is normal listen he wears
the same pig shirt for like 14 years in
a row i mean there's nothing normal
about that 14 years
that's not trust me that ain't the most
unnormal thing he's done dan sure yeah
that just always really bothered me
listen i know dudes do it but stop first
of all just stop just get up and go to
the back how are you ever going to get
married pissing in a bottle
how are you ever going to have a family
you want your kids to come walk in and
see your bottle of piss on that i mean
what the [ __ ] that's life strong trauma
oh
god i might be a degenerate but i never
i don't pee and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
empty bottles and to go boxes i'm not
taking a pause to pee
what
hey you're not gonna pause to pee
what are you an astronaut
well they [ __ ] and piss themselves but
they're actually busy they're going to
space right jeremy is playing
fall guy yeah making his 40th video
about sarah silverman or something
[Music]
i just oh i wanted so bad that to be a
mash-up zach
one small i could make a man one well i
just [ __ ] my floor
[Laughter]
oh my god you guys this clip had me
rolling and disturbed and just
[ __ ] so off the rails
what's your husband jeopardy was a toe
curling answer
uh in life for 400. in common law the
age of this
signaling adulthood is presumed to be 14
in boys and 12 in girls
tom what is the age of consensus
[Laughter]
libertarian alert it's puberty right
that's the answer yes that is crazy age
of consent are you [ __ ]
are you in the clergy or what
he should have asked them to edit that
out yeah really sad
14 boys 12 and girls
the age of consent
wow
sister
hi my name is scott and i'm a boy scouts
leader
and i help at the church on the weekends
where where was his mind out there i
mean that [ __ ] you can't take back you
know that's forever man that guy's gotta
go back to work on monday hey what's up
scott asia consent
oh
god stay away from my uh from my
daughter she's almost there she's almost
12.
we have another stupid one oh wait no
yes so that was good eh pretty
interesting
[Applause]
why did you ask me that what is this no
i'm making a jeopardy joke what is a
self report
thank you
a self report
[Applause]
is when some one inadvertently exposes
themselves
correct
did we make this guy viral dan because i
see this guy everywhere now on tick tock
he's become like a viral meme i think it
was already a little bit of a meme
before we discovered that this guy wide
open
it's possible it's possible yeah so
this is i love him though
every video is the banger
it really is unreal this guy's a
self-defense guru he actually has like a
private security firm and trains people
this is like steven seagal level of
martial arts training
no one like the king stephen
yeah so he's been blowing up on on tick
tock
detroit urban survival training we're
gonna share with you what to do if
someone abducts you and they're sitting
in the back seat with a weapon to the
side of your skull such a such an
obscure
moment to train for by the way
well you never know
maybe i don't know maybe if you're like
a uber driver or something what did you
do if you get abducted and someone has a
gun blank to your head
the correct answer is do whatever they
say yeah exactly
you're [ __ ] you're already [ __ ] bro
detroit urban survival training we're
going to share with you what to do if
someone abducts you and they're sitting
in the back detroit weapon to the side
of your skull
oh
the way that works
number one you move in
grab the barrel and frame redirect the
finger's gonna be caught from the
aggressor and now you have the weapon
easy
that was so unsmooth
you can literally see him like
taking a full two seconds to grab that
thing man the way that works
number one the way that works what's in
front of the gun same time we lift our
arm up which pins the top of the frame
and bro you ain't pinning [ __ ] between a
head seat
that's a soft head seat you couldn't
have been anything when he gets shot in
the arm right there
i don't think it's pointing at his arm
that's the technique right you just get
shot in his head the second that you
start to try and do any of this like
you guys sound like haters
grabbing the
grip
redirecting the weapon you have control
you have control it's easy as that now
go out there and get yourself in this
situation and
yeah i love that dude you can't be
trying that [ __ ] out in detroit that's a
hard city
yeah you ever pulled this move back in
the day no unfortunately
i moved away because i didn't know this
stuff
right now you can go back right now
everyone saw that
this guy says he thinks he's going up
against npcs
[Laughter]
he's playing against bots
oh so funny
there's more of him there's there's
endless i mean endless
videos of him but you know here's
another one
we love it
so right here fingers on trigger ready
to shoot right yep if i move he's going
to shoot
something
putting a gun at your deck
why is he pointing a gun there nobody
would do that also i love in all of his
scenarios they have the gun like
point-blank on your body yeah
isn't that the whole point of having a
gun is that you don't have to be right
next to them
that's why weapons be
hand-to-hand combat
all right well so if you're up against a
guy who's pointing a dick a gun at your
dick for some reason
here's what to do
so right now he can't pull the trigger
why because i blocked it what you're
going here fingers on trigger ready
sure
wait you're dead
so right now he can't pull the trigger
because i blocked it
right here fingers on trigger so wait he
he put his finger in the gun hole
that's a really precise move when your
life is when your dick is on the line
you're for sure blowing your own dick
off
like 100 that's what's happened he's
like okay what you want to do is slip
your finger in the hole
want to put
just like a bugs bunny cartoon you
actually want to stick your finger in
the barrel of the gun oh and if he tries
to shoot it it'll backfire and blow
black soot all over your assailant's
face that's actually a really good
that's a really good idea i'm surprised
he hasn't gone that route yet
what you want to do is have an anvil
drop from the sky in this exact location
what you want to do is paint a fake
tunnel on the side of a cliff
and then have them run into it at full
speed and then they'll get flat like a
pancake that works every time
what you want to do if you're being
followed by somebody is run up to the
top of a cliff
have it be on the verge of breaking
get them to go up on the edge of the
cliff and as the cliff is breaking jump
right off right fall to their death
right and then you actually just stay
floating there somewhere you float and
uh
basically you as long as you don't look
down
i could try to think but nothing happens
i'm trying to think but nothing happens
oh this was the new brittany video that
um
gives us white claw gabe vibes which we
stand
seven million views she is a queen
that's awesome
i think she's just out here being free
and being me
let's read this as much therapy as i've
had to do
against my will being forced to pay and
listen to women telling me how they're
going to further my success it was a joy
no really 10 hours a day 7 days a week
no lie
in this beautiful nation it would only
be fair for me to dedicate my life to
skits
to the wonderful therapists i genuinely
thank you dear hearts for your effort
the end is me celebrating it's clearly
over because my medication is working
america
piss balls and kiss my [ __ ] ass
dude this is brittany unchanged
this is truly
this is a good timeline right when
britney is unchanged unchained i mean we
always joke about the darkest timeline
but this is a good timeline i've
actually i'm starting a new movement
don't say it we gotta get her back on
this conservatorship dude chain her up
you can't even joke about that
i know you're joking but i will miss you
dan
bye bye damn
bye-bye bye-bye honey there's a now a
moveon.org petition with a hundred
million
signatures to get dan fired from the h3
podcast no no no the petition says get
her back on that conservatorship
dueling conservator ship uh petitions
all right let's watch
hi so as your therapist today i'm here
to just ask you a couple of questions um
not here to trouble you i just want you
to be completely relaxed you just relax
um i do the work i'm just gonna ask you
a question i'm here to help you key
number one um so relax totally relax lay
down do what you have to do just a
couple of questions
um don't worry about it everything's
gonna be fine um but the psychosis of
what's going on in your head kind of
goes into mine too so we need to just
clear these blockages
you know what i mean um clear do the
clear way you know so i can read you
well you read me well so i can do my
work
that's what it's about i need to do my
work for you to help you
succeed
yes i'm feeling fine
i've had a great year
i'm having great days
wait is this not the show i think we
need to figure some things out um it is
are you breathing oh it's just a full
skit are you eating well look at her are
you okay daily
and what time do you go to sleep at
night because i'm here to help you
okay
um that's key number one i'm here to
help you fall holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls whoa
girl [ __ ] wow
oh my god ah
holy [ __ ] well [ __ ] balls eh yeah
holy [ __ ] balls hi
what was the context of that last part
as funny as it was she said it's her
celebrating i'm lost oh that was her
celebrating lock her up dude lock her
back up the end is celebrating
okay
interesting i love it [ __ ] [ __ ] balls no
i loved it too to be honest first of all
stan a queen a free queen
it sounds horrible they they obviously
had like fake ass therapist monitoring
her and [ __ ] this this the amount of
[ __ ] that this i mean i'm not surprised
she has like permanent ptsd from being
under the thumbs of these absolute
demons
um but
this is a great sound bite that i'll
forever cherish
daily and what time do you go to sleep
at night cause i'm here to help you
she's also just like funny um she is
like absolutely i'm here to help you oh
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls whoa girl [ __ ] wow
oh my god
holy [ __ ] well [ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls what is a yeah i
mean this is what social media was made
for
you ever think about like back in the
day if the stars then had twitter and
instagram how different we would
perceive them talking about the beatles
led zeppelin you know queen of all these
icons had [ __ ] we're going wow [ __ ]
[ __ ] balls because we think of them with
all this mystique and power
i feel like they'd all be canceled yeah
[ __ ] they did they're all straight up
like essayers no question
like every single one of them i just
mentioned probably
peace and love don't sue me these some
of them are livestock
i feel like after watching that uh
beatles documentary uh we would have
been blessed to have those guys on
social media they were they were [ __ ]
posters they were [ __ ] goofy as [ __ ]
well i think with the exception of
john lennon
beat the [ __ ] out of a girlfriend or two
i was just talking about them being
funny they're all hilarious but i'm
saying like the other i don't think the
other three would be cancelled i feel
like paul mccartney oh yeah ringo george
harrison were like stand-up dudes
and i mean john lennon was
less of a stand-up dude than the other
three i feel like ringo would have been
like super goth you know
listen to a lot of cure and like a lot
of the dark music you know i feel like
zach would have been tagging us to
perform with him okay so this is a
headline from the onion man always gets
a little rush out of telling people john
lennon beat his wife
this is an onion article that
is an all
timer i mean
the truth is though that if he did that
today i mean you can't do that so i
guess back in the day people just beat
their wives though in the
50s it was just openly talked about
sitcoms all the time yeah
yeah so i guess um
but the but i mean paul mccartney and
those other guys seemed like real
stand-up characters
that shut up all seems cool i mean john
was more troubled obviously than it
seems like than the other three yeah he
had a rough upbringing
i mean excuses
[Music]
he just screams mommy
yeah
yeah you believe it's called
mama yeah
you left me
but i didn't leave you
i mean georgia
george traded his wife for a [ __ ]
guitar so i mean
george traded his wife for a guitar yeah
what the [ __ ] you saying
that's the tattoo zack's gonna get
are you referring to the eric clapton
yeah patty boy there was it was yeah
that whole story is super weird
you the song you know the song layla
yeah that was the girl that it was about
it's about george harrison's wife and
then clapton and him traded it's [ __ ]
there's no way that's true yeah oh yeah
look it up no it's true the guitar's
name was lucy it was a 69. that time
george harrison eric clapton had a
guitar duel
i don't think that's no it says of all
the crazy stories exist in the industry
this one about george and eric engaging
in a guitar duel over george harrison's
wife oh oh maybe that by the way did you
guys see that eric clapton made a song
about aunt being his anti-vaccine yeah
i'm not surprised eric clapton is a huge
piece of [ __ ] like an all-time all-time
massive
i love that he came out of retirement to
be like
you're a slave if you get the kovid shot
i believe he did a song with van
morrison called no more lockdown
wait ben moore isn't very morrison like
gigi no re
pardon
what does that mean
he's saying isn't he dead yeah no no no
van marzen stole it what is right i
cannot keep
keep track of all these people
he looks like he's about to croak but no
he's not around gg no rematch
you know that of course
i followed what you meant yeah good game
okay sorry it was like a bad manner
thing when you win a game of starcraft
you say gg no rematch because you're so
good yeah there's no point in playing
again gg no re
i'll start using that
of all the crazy stories
george and eric engaging in a guitar
duel over george's wife something for
the history books harrison and boyd were
married
when clapton fell in love with boyd
what
he made a few passes at her before but
he'd always been rebuffed
for some reason uh she was married do
you mean for some reason
however one night after harrison and
boyd had already been married for a bit
boyd with clapton oh yeah what the [ __ ]
however one night after harrison and
boyd
had already been married for a bit who
wrote this so [ __ ] 10 year old it's
very
yeah there's a lot of type of boyd with
the clapton to listen to his music and
smitten by his lyrics layla was written
by clapton thanks to her inspiration it
said and she was absolutely starstruck
after finding them hanging out together
harrison was floored when clapton
admitted that he was in love with boyd
so it sounds like his wife was
interested in
clapton yeah i think they're leaving out
the detail that i believe george
harrison cheated on her somewhere many
times yeah and so she may have he was a
cheater yeah
i
mean
yeah
i don't think paul was a cheater
no i don't think so yeah paul is just
like a very wholesome guy paul is like
he is so pure he has never
been in any controversy he's never
cheated on his wife he's never hit on
his wife he's never he was with linda
for until she died died tragically of
cancer he loved her till the end
you know joe i mean paul mccartney is
like he's too good for this world i
agree yeah he's a good guy
now ringo that guy [ __ ] this is a
serious message to any girls
peace and lube man oh yeah george slept
with ringo's wife somebody just said in
the chat and i do remember hearing that
story yeah
what yeah they [ __ ] dude
what
you gonna [ __ ] your homie's wife
jesus stannis
also what's up with ringo's wife what
the [ __ ] can you fact check that
i remember hearing that story but yeah
let me uh
george here
i mean it auto-completed on
so after he after asking who she was
going home with
oh she went home with harrison i mean
this doesn't sound like a healthy
relationship guys let's be honest at
this point already during this period
harrison also slept with lingostar's
wife maureen having announced during a
dinner party in front of patty that he
wanted her yeah he's a horny bastard
george
at some point clapton showed up at
harrison's apartment drunk and ready to
throw down but not in the way that you
might imagine he brought a guitar and an
amp and challenged harrison to a guitar
duel something that might seem a bit
silly to some but to musicians is far
better than a fist fight ever could be
okay is this literally like a fifth
grade book report like what am i reading
right now
i don't know how reputable this is
yeah the chance to upstage a friend and
possible rival is something that a lot
of musicians don't take lightly he acts
like they're having like a
samurai sword fight to the death it is
silly
when music is your life the best thing
you can do is use it when you really
need it for something
for two hours clapton harrison dueled
but in the end clapton's music was just
more on point
who was there to judge you know what i
mean
whoa
somebody just dropped a very cold take
in the chat that i i have to address
paul is a complete goof who wrote
horrible songs and kept getting dumped
by models subpar beetle three out of ten
i see i see people saying that which is
just psychotic
whoa
i don't know if they're just trying to
listen i i lean john when it comes to
like the songs with the beatles eileen
john a little bit but
you can't knock paul i mean just watch
the documentary you can see
well on the album get back for sure yeah
yeah no
you're wrong sorry paul mccartney's like
modern modern-day mozart i mean i don't
know what to tell you he's a genius his
first record after the beatles the band
on the run he played every single
instrument on that album
yeah he's quite talented that poll
anyway this this article is like
absolutely like the dumbest thing i've
ever read so and this is somehow the top
article for it what
it's a little odd that that's so good
seo we should reach out
i should be writing i'm sorry i just i
don't believe it i don't believe this
story
the highest okay here it's a famous
story it is famous lucy's yeah well if
the [ __ ] okay here let's see clapton
harrison let's go to wikipedia the qatar
had only been made in armstrong shop for
a few years days when it was purchased
by eric clapton clapton did not pay did
not play this instrument much his
principal
guitar
being his psyche i don't care
um
in august clapton gave the red
as a present to his good friend george
harrison
harrison dubbed the qatar lucy after red
headed comedian lucille ball you guys
understand that your story does not
match up already at all with this
wait we're talking about layla or lucy
no lucy's the name of the guitar
okay so it was named after lucille bald
didn't you say his name after his wife
no layla
layla is patty boyd like one of
clapton's most famous song it was
written
about okay george harrison's wife okay
so um
you're getting the streams crosstalk
okay harrison and the beatles were at
the time recording self-titled album and
been working for several weeks on well
my guitar gently weaves harrison have
been unable to record a lead guitar part
that he was satisfied with moreover
lennon and mccartney were dismissive of
the song and didn't try very hard
knowing that his bandmates would be on
good behavior around a great musician
harrison invited clapton to come into
the studio to play the song telling him
you don't need to bring a guitar you
know i've got a good les paul you can
use clapton overdub
this is just a story about them being
friends
okay yeah why are you reading that
because there's nothing here about this
[ __ ] fable that you guys think where
they actually traded wives over a guitar
battle no i never said anything about
trading wise over a guitar player no no
no no no
find me find me something that wasn't
written by a 14 year old okay as the
primary source and i'll believe it
um
the back
uh the story
of the song layla
her name is patty boyd
if you go to patty boyd's wikipedia page
it has the whole
scoop on that okay but it's very long
and honestly this can't be that
interesting to our uh audience right
well
i find it interesting so oh
what the [ __ ] was that my
call just like randomly dropped
sometimes maybe because we're idle too
fatty boyd
all right i got it i got it
here we go
she's a model she okay so she i mean
yeah she was married to george and then
she was married to eric sounds like she
had
a okay let's go to marriage with eric
they became close friends clapton fell
in love with his wife
clapton briefly dated
her sister because he was obsessed with
her well that's weird
um god clapton seems like a total freak
piece of [ __ ] he is a total piece of
[ __ ]
clapton drew inspiration from the story
of layla
uh based on the story of yadda yadda
when boyd
when boyd rebuffed his advances clapton
descended into heroin addiction
dude
it's just that
there's plenty of fish in the sea my
dude
he's like if she can't have her um it's
heroine for me baby
once cured of his addiction clapton
again pursued boyd
she must have been a real
let me see a photo of her back in the
day
see what you look like
uh
patty patty boyd
young curious what you look like
driving everyone crazy
okay beautiful
right
love her model
what a crazy weird life they had the
bounty between george harrison and eric
clapton like what
you know what they needed to end it like
that one movie uh
with matt damon and ben affleck where
they just have a threesome
they were all in love with the same girl
and they're like we just need to all
have a threesome
the hell was that movie called
i don't know all right i didn't see that
one
so he began to pursue her
actor john hurt later recalled that
harrison clapton staged a guitar duel
over boyd at fryer park
hurt added that it was extraordinary the
air was electric nobody dare say a word
while boyd supports this account clapton
has dismissed its significance
boyd finally left harrison on july 4.
she and clapton were married
they remained friendly with harrison
who took to colin clapton his
husband-in-law that sounds like an urban
legend my friend
wait what part
they said we had a guitar battle it
doesn't say anything over her it said
and then it says that
harrison we didn't we never said the
part about the guitar battle you got
that from the random
i said the guitar i said the guitar the
guitar not a battle the guitar
it sounds like she just liked clapton
and they got together
okay
all right
who cares sorry zach
one of the greatest love songs did come
from that it's just one of those stories
where you're like is that real
you know i like to believe it
it's what gets me through the day
leila
i'm gonna do some heroin if you don't
sleep with me
oh what else we got um
apparently mobility mary died [ __ ]
ripped to the goat
do you see that post on the subreddit
no
yeah pull that up i mean it's real sad
someone kind of proved it definitely
that uh oh my god so i was right
yeah well she looks like she definitely
took her last ride as they say and fast
and furious
mary i'm looking for it
as we wait here's some fresh scooter
coming here cam got it
yo what in the gods [ __ ] green earth
is this you seen this [ __ ]
you can't walk that's better than
walking
do you think they're just goofing around
it looks fun
i don't see any laughter that's there's
a shine right this is like a hillbilly
megazord yo i don't see no smiles i
don't see no
[ __ ] like
there's no kidding there's no joy this
is just
this is just how it be in that family
i mean
that's just the way it is
it's how we ride what better it hits me
no no walking in this family
i was so glad when i saw this because
it's been far too long since we had some
wild mobility content on this channel so
yeah well some of you who are newer to
the channel may not remember the legend
of mobility mary but
she was one of our favorites
absolute favorite characters
she would drive around santa monica on
her mobility scooter filming everyone
and everything and getting into constant
altercations with people
and filming it and putting it on the
internet i mean it was some of the best
content on the internet
and she disappeared one day
and people constantly been wondering
what happened to mobility mary well
unfortunately there is some
evidence that she may have uh
she may have perished
yes this post says
uh
well so that their name is uh linda
stone which i believe we have figured
out before although i don't think we
knew her name was linda for sure the
name was linda
uh and then they found
uh the address for a house that was
owned by linda stone in that area
and i think the real kicker it seems to
be this well hold on the house was on
sale right in a certain kind of
um
like when you die a trust probate or
something like that was what happened
basically when people die they sell
their house correct well show the show
the image because that's the crowning
jewel not that one oh yeah yeah
so this this is one of the images on
zillow i mean [ __ ]
yeah that was it huh that was the
scooter i think that's it
can we buy the scooter
we'd have to buy the house
i want that scooter man how much is the
house
zach you gonna smell the seal on that
thing dude dude legend status let's
spark the whole mobility movement dude i
wouldn't have that [ __ ] gas people
want for her right
i mean let's try to buy that scooter we
should emo we should immortalize it
maybe
maybe you know what we could do is like
dip it in a gold gold cast what's the
thing they do with the plastic epoxy or
the how do you call it
resin yeah dip it in resin like a huge
preservative or put it in like a glass
case
something or some great seed of honor
it's a piece of history man we should
totally get mobility marriage scooter
rip that would be amazing all right
you're gonna work on that so much joy
yeah i'm gonna try yeah this is making
me sad dude
well i mean
this is part of life i mean this is this
is yeah the light the cycle yeah uh the
story goes is that um
she had one too many and was speeding on
that thing just got wrapped around a
tree
excuse me sir
she had really damn this [ __ ] house
is almost two million dollars dude it
looks tiny as [ __ ] well it's santa
monica i know that's insane 1400 square
feet
that's small
it must be really close to the beach
almost 1.9 million dollars they know the
legend lived there man santa
santa monica is oh it was sold though
we're probably too late well we can
we'll listen i think contact the the
buyer right that was my thinking is that
we could reach out and say hey
we actually are interested i mean we'll
pay top dollar but it does appear to
already be sold when did it sell was a
long time ago recently
they
i'm trying to find it i can i can get
the car yeah zach you got the yeah let's
make a genuine effort to get our hands
on that thing man okay i'm gonna get on
that
because they're probably just gonna
scrap it and yeah chat please do not
investigate this we're gonna take care
of it do not contact anyone
thank you you'll make it harder for us
to get it you won't be hoping
i hope they still have it i think it's
back on the market
the house
let's let's not discuss on the air zach
you you'll figure it out and uh
get us a lead on that scooter i will
yeah i heard that she was she she had
reached speeds as high as 70 miles per
hour when she
yeah when she fatally crashed
[Music]
family family family family family
family family family family stop stop
stop why are you saying it what what do
you two why are you too good to say it
why are you sitting there nodding like
you're too good to say family
what's happening what didn't seem
appropriate but i'll say it if you guys
want appropriate what are you talking
about there's no appropriate you hear
the sound you say it
family family family let's do it
family they're family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
families family family
and that
can you get it together
something said as well
do you want to try that again
no no no no no no no please no he had a
shot
uh friend of the show papa john i hate
to do it to him because we love him
but um this was a this is just a
nightmare i'm sorry papa
friends tell you when you're wrong and
uh
well i'm here to tell you [ __ ] up
okay well i can't play the music but you
guys know the meme where it's like
and the guy takes one bite of food
he takes like a bite of like the worst
food you've ever seen
yeah so papa somebody pull that up real
quick
should we show let's show cause we
should show how to properly do it yeah
to just see how far off he really is and
i've seen lots of people trying to do
this and i will say the original nobody
does it like him like he really got that
shredder he's got swag
[Music]
yeah it's a compilation let me find that
just mute it yeah the o.g
no that's another guy where is he
where is he i just saw him
he was outside with glasses his name was
john mcginnis that's him is that him yes
yeah you're right i know him when i see
him he just he takes a bite of the donut
and goes oh that [ __ ] slaps
that's it all right so here's papa
trying to do it
i don't know
what the [ __ ] this is
he doesn't even bite it he's got two
slices he's all over the place that
turns me off there's no rhythm bro don't
you line dance or something don't you do
see though or [ __ ] out there in [ __ ]
tennessee
let me finish kentucky
don't you do some doci does out there in
kentucky square dancing he rolls some
dough does he do let me just play the
music so you can hear off bds
what was that he did it twice like he he
he did he hit the top one twice
it looks like he's having a stroke
look at this pizza watches twice a pause
it's all over the place
jesus
also does he ever eat it no he never
takes a bite the [ __ ] so how does that
actually see
are you seeing that pizza too
it looks like digiorno's honestly yeah
it doesn't look good remember all of the
the pizza score yeah the pizza score
that the crust you can tell the cheese
does not come up to the crust the cheese
has been sitting there for a minute it
looks like that's not a pop of tent man
yo the cheese is hanging on for dear
life too it's flopping around pete
papa what the [ __ ] is this this is my
favorite he pauses and then double does
what
oh stahl bros up on this
i know store-bought pizza when i see all
right
bro
that's digiorno that's frozen pizza papa
who you fooling you've cultivated pizza
experts and now you expect them to look
the other way i'm sorry but no
[Music]
you come to me
[Music]
trying to do the food dance what is this
you spit in my face
you come to me talking about pizza
scores
a perfect rating
what is this just thor about pizza
the day of wrecking will come
papa you break in my heart
and let me tell you something else he's
such a phony this papa john he's got a
pizza slicer a pizza roller without even
a drop of grease on it oh wow good eye
no [ __ ]
you have never used that roller my
friend
i you probably didn't even cook this
pizza
you far fraud
i love pizza and i love people if you
love pizza so much papa you take a bite
of the slice
and now you come into my house a man who
loves pizza dear to my heart learned it
from you
and there's no pizza to be eating this
day my friend
i'm gonna take you out back on the lake
i'll show you a couple slices
[Music]
i've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
and when bo takes over the empire you'll
know
it was me who put him there
when beau was in the house
papa's in the grave
in the house you understand what i'm
saying
[Music]
coward
click of the mouse and papa's in the
house
look at this [ __ ] roller it's a
disgrace
[Music]
this [ __ ] really bought digiorno
for this dumbass tick tock and i bet you
they just dumped it all out afterwards
too
[Music]
this is a disgrace
pop a mess
can you by the way let's just examine
that we've got this papa bless meme made
years ago
from an h3 video and now we got papa
john just independently talking papa
bless hashtag papa blessing his suppose
what the [ __ ] it's power manifestation
right there brother words out of my
mouth
about to manifest some decent pizza in
this kitchen damn let's go i remember
when i'm about to manifest some pizza
into my belly that's right
that's right do you want pizza [ __ ] yeah
let's go porter delicious
let's get some digiornos
give me pizza
pizza
what's your delivery choice i don't care
at my house like nobody delivers yeah i
don't have any good options
me knows sam
don't get dominoes
let's get out let's get an independent
chain let's get independent oh
yeah let's try one of these boutique
pizzas let's get some boutique okay yeah
i've i've never been down to get the big
chains i like to i like to get the
boutique because they care you know we
can they care and we care absolutely
bean pizza
[Music]
what the [ __ ] he said in french oh just
in french um pizza
was that a sound it just for our french
listeners un pizza
no he said he said in real time like a
sound bite no he's
it will be now you can go to battle.com
and use promo code h3tv to uh be able to
speak french just like so
who's down for a pineapple olive
jalapeno pie nope but
nobody will try that i would if i would
eat it with any pizza i just don't like
olives on pizza i'm down i like
pineapple vegetarian that doesn't like
olives sick
what the [ __ ] did you say i like
kalamata olives like those black olives
are weird they have no taste i'm about
to flip this table
i like black olives what kind of olives
do you say the kalamata olives [ __ ]
about my pay grade any olive that's like
the oh my god you guys have weird
opinions
those are good what's next you're gonna
[ __ ] a dolphin wait no you're the one
who wants to get all of like
regardless of what liked olives okay
that's a weird combination fine but
y'all coming out here with strong
opinions about black olives i'm sorry
but that's a staple
i agree with them no listen i know that
you hate them you can't take it back i
don't like them let's be honest your
name is olivia that is oh [ __ ] you hate
yourself
oh
reflect on that all right just get some
pie huh before this all falls apart
before it goes to fisticuffs
olivia
olivia
olivia
olivia stand up
i've been listening i've been listening
to olivia the entire time
why does she say so creepy
i've been listening olivia that's my new
favorite i know that's been stuck in my
head all weekend i always feel like i'm
being hyped up when zach plays it i'm
like
thank you
i've been listening the entire time
listening to olivia the entire time
um oh we have a carlos nft site update
oh yeah oh a good one
all right so someone on pizza ordering
though this is this is serious
all over it
all right so
do we need do we have any do we need to
discuss anything or
get get ethan an olive pineapple and
hollow just get it a small apparently
because i'm the only one right and then
get you generally get whatever they're
getting just the normal stuff at least
one vegetarian one thank you mine's
vegetarian dan
i would eat it it's just it's a little
bit of a weird combo just try will you
try it at least i have tried it other
times and you don't like it it's just
the pineapple and olive in particular
those two just don't gel for me
love said in sweden they have a pizza
called africana it's banana
pineapple chicken and curry the banana
the [ __ ] is [ __ ] but the rest sounds
fine do they cook the banana is a cooked
banana
uh they put this before the oven yeah
wow do you like it
it's let's say it's not as bad as you
would think it is but it's not very good
that banana texture just i don't know
that i'm not into that
it's interesting not good though
so olivia you gotta try my pie if you
have i mean i'm telling you it slaps
it's sweet it's spicy it's salty it's
got it all i like pineapple on pizza
yeah
a lot of people hate pineapple i'm down
with the pineapple i'm also done with
pineapple no problem
it's just the olives that throws me off
i'll give it a try i love jalapenos on
pizza too it's like my favorite topping
let's let's let's go to um
let's head on over to carlos's nft
project so is this just the web appears
to just be a screenshot of their logo
wait this is this is actually yeah
exactly that is
just a screenshot okay so let's go to
their website
no this isn't real
it is real
is this a real thing though i don't know
if this is a real thing
but if you go to their website
what's the actual here look we should go
through the whole process what's the
hidden site has been seized by the fear
by the fbi as part of a coordinated law
enforcement action taken against the
networker ransomware
whoa what
the action has been taken in
coordination wait they're saying no
they're saying people who were visiting
that site were getting ransomware
downloaded on it
uh potentially
oh [ __ ] what's the actual website
bigconnectredemption.com
bit redemption or bitredemption.com so
go go to bit redemption
so that seems to work now on the bottom
left is their company metamorph click
that
no i understand this is real but are
they doing have you ever seen anything
like this before like is this a thing
that the fbi does i don't think so yeah
exactly
they would just shut it like the the
4chan hacker uh like anonymous
background you see that
oh shadowy guy in a hoodie yeah this is
a goof
did someone just [ __ ] with them and
maybe
[Music]
well somebody pointed this out and uh
yeah i wonder who pointed it out
probably the person who did it
bitredemption.com they have one image
back baby
what am i gonna do
yeah it's so sad you buy that one carlos
really thought he was gonna make a
million bucks
this one yeah you think you could buy
that one no no it's self-reliant i know
that it's still doing it it's only on
your browser
let's see
um yeah they canceled all of them right
yeah
tragic there's a flop carlos is in his
flop era
he'll come back he'll have a he'll have
it what are you talking about flopping
that [ __ ] in a
hot a mind a mind uh
sex cult
yeah it's called a sex called how dare
you what did he call it
a mind a hyper mind or something or yeah
what what did he anyway he's in a hyper
mind with 20 women and one man yeah how
dare you say he's in his flop face
oh this is so good you guys you know how
we've theorized conspiracy theorized
that
keemstar is working with cat ryan
cavanaugh it's like it's like
seems it's so obvious okay well keemstar
puts this out he goes on
the goons uh podcast and says this okay
watch this is just [ __ ] great
with these lawsuits i really don't i
didn't know that they were coming
i had nothing to do with these lawsuits
but i do have business with ryan
kavanaugh and it's going to be public
in a month all right
are you ready for the [ __ ] show you're
going to get for that
um
do you think first of all
that it's possible
even remotely possible that someone as
petty is ryan cavanaugh who's literally
answering unsolicited dms asking for
dirt on me do you think it's humanly
possible for keemstar the guy who sends
a dossier on every stupid thing i've
done in my life to anyone i have the
pettiest smallest beef with do you think
it's humanly possible that these two men
could sit in the room and not talk about
me
stupid [ __ ]
especially when one of them was
currently drafting a lawsuit that
included like the life story of the
other yeah he didn't bring that up at
any point who is that intimately aware
of keemstar's life except like maybe me
and uh
that's basically it yeah just me i'm i'm
the only one that cares
but like you're such a [ __ ] liar and
by the way these his pathetic little
goon squad that just [ __ ] like
just cow towels to him and are just such
betas to him they don't even have they
won't even ask him like you didn't even
talk about ethan once with them like you
gotta know that doesn't make any sense
by the way 44 viewers on this stream i
didn't know that they were that's what
keemstar is
well i just love you know keemstars with
the only people that will listen to him
which is apparently 44 people
i had nothing to do with these lawsuits
but i do have business with ryan
kavanagh and it's going to be public
that's going to be a banner
are you ready guaranteed
so this is him just desperately trying
to get ahead of the story because
for anyone that cares it makes them look
so pathetic and bad because as everyone
knows the ryan kavanagh lawsuits are
just a horrible precedent if he were to
win defamation president copyright
infringement would affect everybody
including keemstar but he actually just
so but her about
stuff about whatever happened between us
that he's willing to um
basically risk the greater good for some
petty beef
and
that like goes against everything he
claims to have cared about you're gonna
get for that
i know he's immediately gonna say see
look he's working with him so you you
are you just said you are working with
them you said i am working with ryan
cavanaugh
now i like i have business with but hey
people don't understand
i am a business no follow-up question no
follow-up question well keep on keep
playing i've watched it people don't
understand that dramaalert is like
[ __ ]
you know three to ten percent of my
income if i had to guess like you know i
do a lot of business i do a lot of
things outside of i'm a business
i have a lot of stuff going on
and dramaalert ethan is beyond paranoid
that's a comment in the chat he just
said he works with them
i was right and he confirmed it
he said i have business with ryan
kavanagh
being paranoid man what the [ __ ]
has always been a fun project for me and
it's been
my baby my my place where i can go let
off some steve and have fun right but it
is not the main source of income if it
was the main source of income
uh you know i wouldn't have the the
things that i have and i wouldn't be as
rich as i am so yeah you have to flex
how rich you are to a kid who's shooting
a show out of his closet i'm sure you're
[ __ ] killing it
i'm sure you have to go on a show with
44 views and flux on a kid in a closet
and experience about how rich you are
so pathetic
also you have a quarter million dollar
tax lien on your house yeah i mean you
don't even pay your taxes bro how rich
are you
guys can we just take a moment to uh
myself yes and by the way
i mean like i know i've joked about this
but like what's his property tax like
ten dollars a year
because he lives in buffalo oh i knew
her why are you always ragging on
buffalo what's wrong with buffalo
people i mean it's just
i mean i don't i admittedly don't know
much about buffalo but as you can see i
understand it it's just it's like it's
like you know let's say it's like the um
what's one baker field of uh new york oh
interesting yeah that does put it in
perspective yeah
yeah exactly they brought us buffalo
sauce though and
did they really claim buffalo that's why
it's called that
that makes sense it's kind of a
crackhead sauce
bro
i mean i like what i'm just saying what
the i like it i'm just saying it's the
kind of thing a crackhead would think
about you're not a war path today man
i'm not i'm not criticizing the sign of
[ __ ] buffalo slander is this
i'm not criticizing the sauce but it
takes a crackhead to be like i'm gonna
end it at my lab in my [ __ ] crack
then cooking up something called buffalo
sauce where it's like
some kind of sweet and spicy weird red
[ __ ] yeah
isn't it just like butter and hot sauce
hit the buttons yeah and by the way hey
chill dude all right
all right chill we're trying to do a
show here
i'm with you ethan i mean i like the
sauce you know i'm not saying i like the
sauce what do you want from me i'm just
making a joke about
i mean keemstar lives in buffalo that's
got to bring the property value down for
the whole game so okay that's fair you
know that's true
that's a good point
yeah keemstar the mogul
i have lots of business you guys don't
know about i'm super rich i swear
he invented buffalo sauce oh i'm super
rich and important well
listen to this it was the main source of
income
uh you know i wouldn't have the the
things that i have what do you have a
quad like what does he have that's like
such a flex like he has a quad basement
he does i mean his house seems to be
quite nice from all the videos that i've
seen his house um i think it's not gonna
be his for much longer first of all okay
it's going to get repo'd but this is he
his house is valued at like 200 000
that's how cheap it is to live there
it's really that cheap yeah and i don't
know
i'm saying that that's a lot of money
now
i just want to clarify i'm not i won't
get you a [ __ ] shack in l.a yeah you
can't even buy like a [ __ ] studio
yeah nothing condo can't even get a
condo he has a lot he has neon signs
yeah he has a pool table he is a man
cave yes he is a man cave right
listen i wouldn't have all that i have
i have quads
it's quads
i wouldn't be as rich as i am yes i have
a mortal kombat uh arcade uh cabinet
yeah
he has bandanas and robes in every color
yeah hats
chains so many hats yes i would not have
all i had
i was sitting here nodding like yeah av
you're you're right he does have yeah i
didn't realize he has a versace robe i
mean those aren't cheap
i mean that
this is a bar in his house this is
pretty nice i think that's cool yeah
yeah it's nice i agree now he does this
at the expense of not paying his taxes
and it's probably all going to be taken
from him but he does it at the expense
of his soul look at him i mean he's 40
years old in a bar in his basement by
himself is that a happy man to you i'm
not saying listen i'm not defending
keemstar no i'm saying he has nice stuff
but this claim that he's like i wouldn't
be so rich
and have all the things i have
right if i wasn't basically hitler
it's funny and i'm sorry if it's like
classes or out of touch or something
because obviously owning a 200 000 house
is a huge accomplishment but
it's just the way he says it is funny to
me and i hope you understand where i'm
coming from with peace and love thank
you
death to all jews
that's what game star says
now he's comparing me to hitler
dude play the sound by so people know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
damn you ain't wrong [ __ ] houses are
cheap
okay you'd have to play it so loud
that hurt
yeah the house is so cheap because it's
a [ __ ] i gotta move to buffalo yeah what
are you seeing tell me what you're
seeing like
a three bedroom two bath 160 k
exac that's what i'm saying buffalo is
the [ __ ] anus of the
country for the place to be four bedroom
one bath because 130 average temperature
there year round is like negative 20
degrees oh it's super cold yeah like
it's basically canada
so i guess that makes sense love says i
don't know if you're goofing but he has
a lot of money he's also in the crypto
um okay i mean that's what he says i
don't believe it
no he i've seen screenshots of his
crypto wallets and stuff okay so how
much was in it
like 500k
so he owes half of that on his house
lane
i'm not defending him in any way
obviously but i do think he has money
just
i believe he has money you know i i i
believe he has some money but
i'm being a youtuber for that long i
mean you gotta be sitting on some cash i
just think it's funny he's flexing on
this on boblex who's sitting in a closet
about how rich he is oh yeah for sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is a turbo tax that actually uh
saying make sure to do your taxes it'll
be like keemstar popping your head out
the
window or something i don't know what it
means
give that tax lien can we show it i mean
it's known right i'm not yeah he was
talking about it okay i'm not saying
anything out of pocket no he gave an
explanation
that i got to be honest didn't
really add up to me but well let's
listen to it i want to hear this [ __ ]
idiot talk about his tax lien it's
awesome
i ain't got no [ __ ] tax liens on my
ass
i'll tell you that
see if i i i gotta bring bob lex on just
to tell him how rich i am
[Laughter]
yeah well you think keemstar is rich i'm
i'm above understand we should be from
i'm bobby you stan boby i stand
anytime i'm looking for anything
you could you could push back a little
bit bobby on this claim that i didn't
know anything about this i just sit in a
room with ryan kavanagh scheming on
projects
that are coming out like
is he going to be working for trailer
fight club or whatever he did the
commentating on the uh
some boxing match recently right
was that a trailer thing i don't
remember if it was a trailer thing no
wait wasn't it it was bryce hall and um
yeah that was the ace family
i wonder if he got bigger and i want to
be as rich as i am so
well that's not true by the way like you
said he's made enough money from doing
youtube to pay for a buffalo house in
buffalo but and and a couple of
mortal kombat cabinets
i'm having a hard time finding that
i saw a video of him talking about why
he has a lien on his house um
not down with the classes convo just
shut up
we're having fun
shut the [ __ ] up i love you and i'm glad
you're here but just shut the [ __ ] up
thank you
a piece of love yeah of course
you've got to acknowledge the house in
buffalo even if you can't afford a house
which most people can't 200 000 a lot of
money it's cheaper than almost
everywhere in the country in buffalo
okay it's funny keep starting why do i
got to explain myself you don't this is
a [ __ ] joke you don't it's funny
it's funny
all right not down with this class is
convo then [ __ ] just stop watching
oh yeah but actually do keep watching
because we no we love you we love
everybody and we don't want to uh
we don't want to lose a single one of
you there's surprises throughout the
whole stream
there are surprises throughout no
skipping yeah
um
okay and then there's a oh there's new
cav cav tweets
yeah what do you guys think he's still
keeping him up isn't that interesting
he's not erased them yet
like the harvey weinstein shout out is i
don't know if he knows how to it's not
like he runs a social media company or
anything yeah you can't really expect
him to understand that let's see
response uh
and kavanaugh says 90 of black deaths by
are by black people blm funded by george
soros trying to create conflict
interesting what a nice little
anti-semitic conspiracy theory new
wrinkle in the whole thing little antis
well he's jewish which is why it's weird
to see him on the george soros thing but
nice little uh
yeah is this racist i mean this this is
pretty
well i mean the the blm stuff yeah um
the the anti-semitic
thing i mean he's not probably the man
he probably doesn't see it that way he
just thinks that george soros controls
he's just actually it proves how dumb he
is because he's fallen down the right
wing uh conspiracy
and he doesn't realize that this is an
anti-semitic uh
trope and he's f he's basically
has internalized anti-semitism wow
look at that
but 90 of black deaths are by black
people bml is funded by george soros is
pretty racist right yeah
yeah
yeah he sucks
he uh
he sucks i feel like you when you see
someone tweet this it's like i know
everything about you it's like i get it
i know exactly who you are
and the fact that he's like this
self-serving elite who got his money
from his dad who like committed art
fraud
i mean the guy comes from good stock
the whole thing is there let's do a
retweet here we'd like
um
let's see
let's add racist to the mix
do we like that is can we say this is
racist i mean it is yes yeah yeah we
like that
maybe i'll put his i'll add his name
i'm not saying that
ryan he had a gamer moment can we say
brian cavanaugh he did gamer mode he had
a heater gamer moment
should we add a picture of him and
weinstein maybe for the algorith
to have it on his google page that was
cool
so my my fear with that love is that
once you add photos it becomes kind of
you lose the message of the retweet the
quote tweet oh yeah maybe just gets a
little messy looking
ryan kavanagh
add racist to
the description
he's a racist
love that
don't we love that folks
we love it
we love it yeah if everyone wants to go
participate
and in this twitter conversation
here i'll participate myself let's see
what is this message fupa trooper for 16
months
member for 16 months you bring this on
yourself because of woke ass hassan all
caps
i'm plenty welcome on my own she he's
saying that i by having hassan on the
show
i bring woke people who say i don't like
the classes thing maybe because he's a
socialist you know for sure hassan would
oh i'm referencing uh
that message from yeah i see i see
why are you remember for 16 months
measly little love
no they're
fine yeah they're fans they're just
saying
they're saying maybe there's two i guess
maybe i misinterpreted that you know
what i'm sorry i yelled at you i don't
want to ever yell at one of you guys
again i know it works for some people
i don't like yelling at you guys
i thought it was awesome yeah i feel
like i'm elected too you guys do the
yelling i'll be i'll be the good guy
your mom how about that
the thing is the thing is that people
are just leaving comments and passing
they're not trying to get you know
called out so we we stand a class we
stand a uh advocate for the poor
and owning a 200 000 house is a huge
accomplishment
and if you want to hear about it uh
i can i can get a call going for
if you're getting the closest class i
don't agree
with the sentiment that what you were
saying was classist though because
you're specifically talking about his
claim like he's the one claiming
like he's loaded
and you're poking holes in that
narrative it's not
well i guess
loaded is relative right like some
people would say oh he's worth two
hundred thousand dollars that's loaded
right i mean
but who you know what i mean yeah no i i
know what you mean
[Music]
wow ryan kavanagh racist damn that's
crazy y'all
that's crazy that's crazy
i wonder if snoop dogg oh here i'll
attack snoop dogg i wonder if
snoop dogg
has seen this and that's actually a good
point because
if he's working with people that care
about blm they should see
that he thinks blm is just a conspiracy
funded by george soros
that's a pretty toxic uh that's a gross
view that's a disgusting view
that i think a lot of people would
probably
want to know he felt
right
[Music]
yeah also white people using the black
on black violence
as like a way to distance themselves is
also very problematic
his existence is problematic
that is correct from head to toe that
man
loses problems
and even the clothes he wears for
christ's sake
he's just a [ __ ] degenerate creep
you know
here we found a cav cav tweet when he
was drunk black out right before he got
in a car probably
we do we have no way of knowing that
how could we know that he was being wet
and reckless i just based on
the patterns of his existence wait no
i'm seeing the tweet now
deadline owned
same variety mike fleming makes up
information for his stories misleading
and fault does this guy just make a
hobby of like accusing everyone of
defamation
i mean he's trump he's like trump
wannabe well trump doesn't drink which
you're right look at that second message
what the [ __ ] was going on so yeah so
here he types
d h interval denna whoa out me and wrote
an article it wasn't kirk
then
new article accusing me of untruth first
they're bad reporting clearly very
passionate about this topic
there's a hunger for this character to
come back
yeah
hoping deadline sends me a cease and
desist
in the marvel universe i'll post it
along with my letter and info on them
it's interesting to
it's interesting to kirk ching girls
it's interesting to king girls finish
with scenes or else
yeah exactly
what a [ __ ] loser
i mean he is a loser like he has so much
right but ultimately what is a loser
it's not about what you have materially
and i'm not even convinced he has a lot
materially but first of all his success
is all owed to his dad
uh who has committed his own frauds of
selling a fake picasso
and then he makes a [ __ ]
he makes a
production company totally bankrupts it
against like he had
despite having a string of hit movies he
was like the hollywood maker
to [ __ ] that up bankrupted it now he's
moving on to triller where he
sues people for saying naughty words
about him on the internet i mean the guy
is a [ __ ] loser and spends his
thanksgiving getting into flame wars
with wikipedia mods and beefing with a
[ __ ] comedy youtuber i mean yes he's
a [ __ ] loser i'm quick on
thanksgiving this man is [ __ ] posting to
instagram about me i'm more on his mind
than his own family
i mean that's a loser
you know
[ __ ] you know
plus
his apps flipped on top of it you can't
even make a unflipped app
yeah so let's see um
wait this isn't flipped
oh we didn't watch the new channel 5 the
talladega
we did it i watched it at home it's good
he's a funny one
well i guess we've been going how long
we've been going we've been going for
two hours 50 minutes and 52 seconds this
is the first time we're doing long
episodes on this christmas uh season my
friends
anything else you guys want me to talk
about family family family family family
family family family family family stop
i like the shot of zach just plotting
when to end it
oh we didn't talk about like any of our
things for headlines today
like at all there's no headlines it's
just we need to well there was the
jake paul uh fight
yeah
but i feel like it's a long story maybe
we'll save it for friday because it's
kind of meaty i think true we should
save it just because we didn't get a
chance to um
properly vet it the way we'd want to to
see if it gets claimed yes yeah i agree
if it doesn't get claimed i'll watch the
whole damn episode you know what i mean
on that ship
it was good i watched it
it looks good i really like it it looks
way better than it should because i i
watch a lot of reality shows
that looks really good i mean yeah and
fousey was so off the [ __ ] rails
crazy what dan
it pains me to read this but
caitlyn a seven-month member says in
zack's defense i work in a doctor's
office and i feel like the height is
recorded wrong for tall guys because we
can hardly reach the top of their heads
what are we celebrating and zach's
defense i was just i was stretching that
he happened to be that he might be
telling me that his weird ankle
i think the doctor did say i don't think
you're like yeah the doctor has measured
me wrong before i don't think you're
lying
[Music]
i don't think you're 6'3 though
but i don't think you're lying
[Laughter]
um you just plug in merch now
true yeah h3shop.com
stop
thank you
thank you
um family we had some family big donors
today
family
family family family family stop go
ahead dan uh we had some big donors
today that i didn't get a chance to read
out that i would like to hit on real
quick if that's cool
love to let's see uh
casey capstick donated 50 bucks at ethan
i'm about to come for you leave buffalo
alone it's the best hashtag bill's mafia
like the buffalo bill all right um
the only thing i don't like about
buffalo is that keemstar lives there
so if i mean
love you
love your city
love the sauce balance each other out so
you know what i take it all back
i love you and god bless god bless the
city of buffalo
uh
evan donated 50 bucks said long time
viewer i want to say around the ken bone
video but just want to say hello i
really enjoyed you and eli and all the
crew also shout out to my friend
courtney
for me who's also a fan
shout out are courtney
shout out to courtney who's hopefully
not a predator or something
like the girl you shouted out courtney
actually looked into it and she's a
convicted
sex offender top of the sub
peace and love from columbia missouri
well thank you evan thank you
um i know there was a hundred dollar one
i didn't see that in the list here did
it get buried it must have got buried
here it is
from christopher britt just popping into
the brick 100 buckaroonies just popping
in to shout out the crew for all their
great work and i'm a production pastor
at a church so i appreciate the high
quality work you all put in well thank
you chris thank you brick the brook love
the show and i've been watching for over
a year now always a great escape from my
everyday return and then gave us one of
these
the break you're not the wait that's not
the brick is it
is that still the brick it's the shocker
bruh brit
oh it's the brit yeah no brick sorry
shout out the brut
sorry
so sunny
people your people stand in your makeup
by the way olivia
thank you everybody do you wanna know
you have good makeup
i mean i know that i spend time on it
and i enjoy doing you're good at makeup
yeah you could be a makeup guru
i don't think i'd be good at
that
like talking to a camera by myself
every behind the scenes people ask for a
makeup tutorial from the living it's got
to happen oh would you do that you do
the hand thing all the time though well
i do it as a joke i don't i don't do it
i can't do it like real
maybe if i get like more comfy in front
of a camera but okay at this point i
don't see myself just sitting and
speaking okay
all right but thank you all it's very
nice
love the makeup shout out to olivia's
makeup ladies and gentlemen oh this is a
just a five dollar donation but it makes
me sad because i think they're probably
right alert mobility mary's house has
been flipped the scooter is long gone
the house is for sale has been relisted
for sale on zillow wait so what's the
sale what's the price now did it sell
for 2 million it sold for like 1.6 now
it's like at 1.9 so that's a cheap flip
so the man my contact message me the
phone numbers and llc owns it now
so sounds like a flip yeah yeah that's
still called though oh we gotta do our
due diligence absolutely we gotta just
try it yeah absolutely
uh
god that'd be so good if we got it how
[ __ ] awesome would that be i would
spend a lot of money to immortalize it
maybe they're fans you know what could
be could if we use it and build like
you can do like a black silhouette to
represent like who she was those even
though we never saw her we never know
what you look like you could put like a
big
shadow
kind of [ __ ] like i mean she probably
was big
right that's a big heart for sure
i think she's probably got some girth
and weight definitely yeah
so you don't know that
well it's just sorry she wasn't she
needed a mobility scooter so yeah this
one i mean
in my i always imagine it was like a
mobility due to weight issue and not
like
not and not like something yeah yeah oh
i always pictured it was just like by
choice
mobility by choice yeah
mobility's good
oh she's a faker she seemed like the
type you just wanted to be on a scooter
i think that's only
ethan it's only nice ethan's the only
one
without needing it
i mean yeah
my wife went out for pizza without me
um anyway
anything else dan
i mean there's a bunch more but um if
you want to wrap it up that's uh that's
cool well ryan cavanaugh is literally
dudley from harry potter
that's interesting
from gigi
you guys remember dudley
nobody
wait yeah i remember dudley i gotta read
this one because this is kind of
fascinating this is a 50 donation from
austin pruitt zach
buy an inversion table
you sit for work when practicing and
when practicing guitar your spine may be
compressed just got an inversion table
from my father and i we are farriers we
both gained almost an inch in height
much love
no [ __ ] shot what this is the table
look at this
what dan
i mean
wait is this
yeah yeah
i mean i don't know if i want to hit
that you know what
you know what
ela was thinking about getting one of
these for her back pain i mean that'd be
cool really supposed to help with that
i guess so yeah interesting it's
supposed to take all the pressure off
your spine
wait they got taller from this
they said an inch
in an inch who needs surgery that's like
100 000 surgery right there
that's crazy turn upside down boy
this is awesome well i'll buy one if you
want to do it at the i'll love to record
it yeah that could be cool how long have
you got that wait how long are you
supposed to stay in it i wonder
you want to do the show from it
that'd be kind of cool yeah
i feel like i'd get like nauseous in a
way i think i would pass out in like two
minutes i'd be down to try it though
let's buy one it's only that's 5.50 i
mean okay that's a lot for they're super
once i'll buy one for 550 and be like
bobby this is how this is how i have the
nice things i have
550
chart
pay me 300 bucks i'll make you one
i'd rather buy one we could call it we
could call it the flipped chair the foot
would be flipping let's buy one dan
i mean just give me the money i'll i i
can get some rope and i don't
have some each of us have a different
unique chair
exactly upside down dan and scorpion
oh that's true here this could be you
zach
[Laughter]
generating electricity for the office
a human windmill that'd be sick
shredding may i ask what the [ __ ]
may i ask what the [ __ ] isn't this for
abs
like ab workouts no you just lay there i
don't think you
you use your muscles for stretching out
your spine there like back when i was a
kid the commercials for this table were
like
all the rage
really it was on at least nickelodeon or
something but the one you're talking
about i think is the ab one i'm thinking
of because my grammar the
infomercial yeah you're right yeah i
think that's that's a different this is
specifically for back pain
you're just supposed to just kind of
hang there well you've seen those ones
with the kids with extreme scoliosis
where they get a screw in their skull
and they suspend by their neck and spin
in circles
i swear to god
it's super
interesting
someone pulled that up
i mean there's a kid doing it but he
looks really happy like he doesn't look
like he's in pain
and i was reading apparently it's not
painful at all it feels good it's to
relieve pain and straighten their spine
and if you have like really debilitating
um
uh
scoliosis from birth
then they install like screws in your
skull
in the top and side and screw in this
machine
so you can just suspend
i linked it
it's not that bad is it
no it shows they're creepy
a spine surgery oh that's not what i
want to see i mean why go through all
that when you could just do this
right and then there's and then in
russia this is what they do
it has a 50 chance of death but uh the
other 50 report being really happy with
it
vladimir putin
i love the titles what in the middle age
[ __ ] is this
it's awesome it's the best video ever so
much power
oh wow
that'll that'll help the back
in russia
what is this machine
in russia we drop weights to your limbs
putin
damn stretch armstrong so yeah here's
the video
the kid is smiling oh
this i haven't seen this yeah so he
actually has screws in his soul that's
how he's
but apparently it's like he likes it it
feels good it's not it's just so
interesting yeah i could see that
feeling good if your spine is out of
alignment
and when you're like when you weigh
barely anything it's a lot less intense
to be dangling like yeah he he doesn't
weigh a lot
but you know i after having a son i just
i have so much empathy and affection for
kids like this kid is such a champ yeah
why would this horrible [ __ ]
he slams into it yeah they could not
supposed to swing around like that i
think i think they are i've seen someone
else doing it you're supposed to swing
around
but this kid is born with this
[ __ ] up illness he's got to get
screwed in his head and he's still out
there smiling
look put a guy
kicking toys and spinning around
[Applause]
he just lands
watching me just
[ __ ] awesome dude love that guy
sick
you're [ __ ] canceled again no no he's
funny no there was this a chat comment
that got me pretty good somebody said it
looks like a dark souls boss
true
halo gravity traction halo gravity
traction is a way to pull the head and
spine
upwards carefully that didn't look
careful applying a slow stretch to the
spine doctors do this by attaching a
halo
to a pulley system
over several weeks weights are added to
the pulley system slowly pull the head
upward the pole is called traction kids
stay in the hospital during halo gravity
retraction wow it's like a whole
extended stay huh
i think i got a killing spree with the
halo gravity traction this past weekend
you saw gravity traction what that's my
favorite weapon in the new halo the
gravity tractor attraction
all right
that's about it hey guys
that's it this wednesday
family's a reunion
is being recorded and then for the
public it'll be up tuesdays for members
will be thursday
it's friday [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yes
um
for members it's up wednesday night for
public thursday night thank you to our
members by the way
who we love so well
thank you thank you and thank you
everyone for watching we love everyone
and um
we love everyone what can i say
except keemstar and however you want or
i mean ryan kavanagh
what
yeah well i don't love harvey weinstein
right i don't want to put that out there
uh so yeah tune in to the families we
have actually a really great show
planned for the families reunion yes we
do it's gonna be a lot of fun
a show-stopper for the holidays
yes indeed and um
that'll be instead of off the rails this
week
so my friends thank you for joining us
love y'all i'm sorry to that one person
i yelled at i do i i don't want to
now i'm just imagining all the drama
channels being like ethan had to [ __ ]
the fans moment
remember that happened before
they're coming either way ethan said
[ __ ] the fans
i don't say [ __ ] the fans i love the
fans
love them all
family family family family family
family family family guys guys guys we
got to get synced up hold on
you set the pace you set the tempo
came in and it was at a totally
different time let's start let's start
over
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family
every time love
i don't know what to do guys
i have to lead it i think you have to do
it off you you have to do it like
intentionally early i am but i think you
guys have to like follow me
that's not going to happen
keep dreaming buddy
now okay dude
actually love's coming out soon though
you're coming out soon right
that's right
that's right
it's exciting
yeah you can get love in here
all right my friends uh wishing you a
happy week we'll see you soon and uh hey
without family
we have nothing
that's right
that's right not right
[Music]
family family family family family
family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family